Farewell.
Greetings.
Journey well.
Welcome.
The depths of a dream.
They run, they bite, they flee, they die.
Swarms of fur and teeth and tail drown each in every room.
So Leute, ah ja.
Ah ja.
Ich bin übelst kaputt Leute.
Ich habe gerade eine Tür zusammengebaut.
Besser gesagt ein Tor.
Zusammengebaut.
Ah es sind Akte.
Aus so kleinem Gitter Zeug.
Und eins muss ich sagen, was sich echt gelohnt hat.
Was sich wirklich gelohnt hat.
Was ich mir gekauft habe, was sich wirklich rentiert hat.
Und zwar.
Ich musste.
Also das.
Das war quasi.
Ein Rahmen.
Mit Stäben drinnen.
Plus das teilweise.
Abgeschnitten werden musste, weil es zu viele Stäbe waren.
Und ich hatte mir mal vor einer Weile ein.
Ich glaube 3000 oder so etwas gekauft.
So einen Satz hier hatte ich mir mal.
Oder das da.
Ich glaube das da.
Das da.
Das Teil hatte ich mir mal gekauft vor einer Weile.
Und da habe ich das Sägeplatt oder halt das Metall.
Dieses Metall.
Es ist ja kein Sägeplatt musste ich lernen heute im Internet.
Sondern es ist eine Trennscheibe.
Muss ja da ganz korrekt sein.
Drauf gemacht.
Und nach ein bisschen.
Funken.
Funken sprühen.
Konnte ich die Metall Stäbe.
Ich wusste nicht so viel Metall durchschneiden.
Ich wusste 2, 3, 4.
8.
12.
14.
Ich wusste 14 so ungefähr.
Was soll denn das sein.
Halben Zentimeter dick.
Durchschneiden.
Mit dem da hinten hier.
Da wo Dremel 32.
Dremel 38 irgendwie drauf steht.
Genau.
Hier unten rechts mit dem Ding.
Das hat ganz schön gelitten.
Aber es hat echt gut funktioniert.
Es hat Funken gesprüht ohne Ende.
Das habe ich auf dem Küchentisch gemacht.
Ich habe gehofft dass er das überlebt.
Also ich habe es auf dem Küchentisch fest geklemmt.
Und dann dran geschnitten.
Es hat echt gut funktioniert.
Es hat sich jetzt schon mal gelohnt so ein Ding zu kaufen.
Ich glaube das ist das was ich mir geholt habe.
Der Fachmann nennt es abflexen.
Die Geräusche.
Die Geräusche die das Ding gemacht hat.
Und das was ich von manchen Baustellen höre.
Das ist wirklich sehr ähnlich.
Das ist nicht was die machen.
Die schneiden Metall ab mit so komischen.
Bisschen größeren Dingern halt.
Mit der Flex und nicht mit so einem kleinen Ding.
Ich gucke mal kurz ob das das war was ich bestellt habe.
Mal kurz gucken.
Aber relativ sicher.
Nicht dass ich jetzt hier irgendwie Mist empfehle oder so.
Drehmüll gucken.
Multi, ne den habe ich nicht bestellt.
Ich habe den 3000 bestellt.
Ich glaube das da habe ich dann bestellt.
Was hat den meins gekostet?
Zeig mal her.
Ja das für 60 Euro habe ich bestellt.
Guck mal ich habe sogar das kleine bestellt.
Weil ich wie gesagt gar nicht vor hatte.
Großartig was damit zu machen.
Genau 59 Euro hat es gekostet.
Und ich meine ohne Scheiß.
Mit so einem kleinen in Anführungsstrichen billig Ding.
So einen halben Zentimeter dicke Metallstäbe durchschneiden.
Das ist nicht ohne gewesen.
Ich habe mich erst nicht getraut.
Also erstmal habe ich überhaupt nicht gecheckt.
Das ist das Original drin.
Erstmal habe ich überhaupt nicht gecheckt wie es funktioniert.
Man sieht es ja hier auf dem Bild.
Aber ich war so dumm und habe mir das Bild nicht angeguckt.
Man muss das abschrauben.
Dann also man muss das da abschrauben.
Dann kann man das hier lockern.
Wenn man das hier lockert kann man so einen Aufsatz rein machen.
Und dieser Aufsatz der ist so spring loaded.
Also sprich du musst das so hinter drücken.
Dann reinklipsen und wieder loslassen.
Aber ich habe es ohne.
Was ist das da hinten?
Na ja das ist bei mir auch dabei.
Da kann man so um die Ecke drehmeln.
Ich habe es aber ohne.
Ich habe es aber ohne Anleitung geschafft.
Ich hatte dann aber.
Ich hatte dann aber Schiss.
Dass es mir abspringt.
Weil ich habe das noch nie benutzt.
Und ich habe nicht die Anleitung gelesen.
Und ich habe gedacht wenn du es jetzt nicht richtig dran hast.
Dann fliegt dir gleich mit.
33.000 Umdrehungen die Minute.
Die Scheibe um die Ohren.
Ich habe sogar eine Schutzbrille aufgesetzt.
Ich setze nie Schutzbrille auf sonst.
Aber da hatte ich echt ein bisschen Schiss vor.
Wenn da so ein Metall.
Wenn da so ein Schafes Metallblatt.
Mit 33.000 Umdrehungen die Minute.
Durch die Wohnung fliegt.
Ja ne ne ne.
So aber es hat zumindest funktioniert.
Und wie gesagt ich hatte übel Schiss.
Als ich das.
Muss übrigens noch mein Stash hier.
Zeug aufräumen.
Ich hatte übel Schiss als ich angefangen habe da zu drehmeln.
Zu flexen zu was auch immer.
Also flexen ohne flex.
Dann hat es auf einmal Funken gesprüht.
Und ich habe mich nicht gedraht weiter zu schneiden.
Weil ich gedacht habe fuck das geht gleich kaputt.
Bis ich mir da gedacht habe okay.
Scheiß drauf das geht nicht ab.
Das musst du machen.
Und irgendwann ist es mir klar geworden.
Natürlich wirft das Funken.
Was soll es denn auch sonst machen wenn das gerade durchgeschnitten wird.
Und dann habe ich einen richtigen Failmove gemacht.
Oder auch Big Brainmove.
Small Brainmove habe ich dann gemacht.
Richtig Small Brainmove.
Und zwar.
Wahrscheinlich hat es jeder schon mal gemacht.
Der damit aus Versehen.
Der damit was abgeschnitten hat.
Ich habe danach an die Schraube gegriffen.
Und wollte sie rausziehen.
Die zwei Teile.
Und dreimal könnt ihr raten.
Was dann passiert ist.
Also sprich.
Ich habe die.
Ich habe diesen Metall.
Nicht die Schraube was erzähle ich.
Diesen Metallstift.
Durchgeschnitten und wollte dann die zwei Hälften rausziehen.
Ja.
Das war ein bisschen heiß.
Aber ich habe mir den Daumen verbrannt.
Aber danach wusste ich.
Und das.
Der Scheiß wird richtig heiß.
Ich habe mir dann so ein kleines Auf.
So ein kleines Behälter genommen.
Wo ich den Kram reinwerfen kann.
Und habe ein bisschen Wasser reingemacht.
Und ich habe die Schraube da reingeworfen.
Das hat gezischt.
Also überleg mal wie heiß der Scheiß wird.
Also wenn du Metall in das Wasser wirfst.
Dann weißt du okay.
Das war ordentlich heiß.
Habe ich irgendwas überlesen hier.
Was ist denn hier im Chat schon wieder los?
Was?
Es gibt von der AfD jetzt eine App.
Um Nutzer der Corona App zu...
Hä? Und dann?
Was macht man dann?
Geht man denen dann aus dem Weg?
Oder was?
Also was hat man denn davon?
Wenn man Leute mit der Corona App identifiziert.
Wäre die App warden.
Nicht mal was für den Stream.
Bisschen gucken welcher Tracker.
Was ist das denn?
Kenne ich nicht.
Leute ich muss ein bisschen Kreiselgrind machen.
Ich muss gerade ein bisschen Kreiselgrind machen.
Und danach.
Wenn ich meinen Kreiselgrind
mal eine Map lang befriedigt habe.
Da müssen wir mal schauen.
Ich will nämlich mal gucken.
Was es für Kameras auf Aliexpress gibt.
Mir ist nämlich eine Kamera.
Ich habe ja die hier.
Zeig es euch mal.
Ich habe mir hier ein paar billigste
Ami-China-Cams
mit Custom-Firmware gekauft.
Nämlich die hier.
Und die ist mir verreckt.
Also die sind teilweise noch billiger.
Das ist viel zu teuer hier.
Ich hatte ja 5 Stück davon.
5 Stück von den kleinen bestellt.
Und das Problem ist.
Die sind ja eigentlich nicht für einen Außenbetrieb gedacht.
Diese Kameras.
Es gibt so Outdoor-Kondome.
Nenne ich es mal.
Für diese Kamera.
So was hier.
So ein Silikon-Gehäuse.
Und so ein Silikon-Gehäuse.
In weiß hatte ich drum herum.
Das ist im Prinzip.
Das ist wie gesagt so ein Kamerakondom.
Wenn man es so will.
Und so das hatte ich hier drum.
Hat auch wunderbar funktioniert.
Aber jetzt ist der Micro SD-Kartenslot.
Wohl verreckt beim letzten Regen draußen.
Also war doch nicht so sicher.
War doch nicht so dicht.
Das da habe ich. Genau das da.
So sah das bei meiner Kamera aus.
War wohl doch nicht so dicht.
Und jetzt ist es kaputt.
Was es da so gibt.
Alter mein Inventar.
What the fuck.
Erst mal.
Ideen.
Geht das gar nicht so schlecht.
Das sagt.
Das ist für mich ganz okay.
Also für mich nicht.
Aber ansonsten glaube ich ganz okay.
Das.
Ist auch ganz okay.
Aber nicht für mich.
Der Ring könnte gut sein.
Wenn er irgendwas anderes hätte.
Außer diesen Evasion Crap.
Ich brauche Scrolls.
Warum sind meine Scrolls leer?
Was ist denn das?
Ah fuck.
Und sonst noch.
Das Müll.
Müll.
Noch mehr Müll.
Naja.
Ziemlich Müll.
Praxis.
Alles klar.
Keine Ahnung ob das was taugt.
Ich habe jetzt meinen Preise Check
Skript nicht am Start.
Nicht diese Homesacker gab auf GitLab.
Und die entfernt Android Apps.
Die Tracker Logging Dienste.
Da kann man entweder alles selektiv.
Ich stream ungern von Android.
Das ist immer so hakelig.
Hey das ist nicht schlecht.
Der ist ganz gut.
Der Ring ist.
Er könnte ein bisschen mehr Chaos Resis haben.
Dann hätte der 30 Chaos.
35 Chaos wäre der eigentlich ganz gut.
Live fehlt auch. Aber der ist ganz okay.
Crap.
Warum habe ich so viele Unix gerade im Info?
Dreck.
Wobei.
Müll.
Oh.
Geht so.
Egal.
Hauen wir mal den ganzen Scheiß weg.
Die Maps müssen wir behalten.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal eine Runde Kreiselquanien machen.
Und dann gucken wir ein bisschen China.
Da haben wir nebenbei.
Was behalte ich jetzt mal? Den.
Den. Den. Die. Die. Die.
Die zwei kann ich jetzt machen.
Ich habe noch ein bisschen wenig Leben.
Das ist das nächste was ich bei meinem Gear upgraden muss.
Weil mein Gear ist an sich
eigentlich noch ziemlicher Müll.
Das einzige gute was ich habe.
Was halbwegs was taugt ist.
Die Chest. Die ist richtig gut.
Die ist auch ex. Die. Also.
Das Ding ist echt teuer.
Soll ich euch mal zeigen was das kostet wenn man das
sich jetzt kaufen möchte.
Trade. POE.
Das Ding ist echt massiv teuer.
Socket.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Meine Rolls sind
auch ganz ok.
Also sprich
mit den Socken die hier
auch beliebt sind. Da könnte ich
locker 5, 6
vielleicht
Exhauls oder so für bekommen.
Wenn die Rolls
gut sind und das ist ein 6 Link
mit den passenden Sockeln und so. Also sagen wir mal 5 Stück
vielleicht. Also die Chest ist echt
poggers.
Woher hast du einen 6 Link bekommen?
Gekraftet.
Big brain craft.
Könnt ihr
eine Linux Distro empfehlen?
Dann installiere ich den Scheiß neu.
Was brauchst du denn für eine
Linux Distro? Für was?
Ich muss so gucken
dass es keine Damage Reflection gibt.
Und ich möchte auch nicht
verrecken ehrlich gesagt.
Habt ihr den für meine Eltern
eingerechnet? Suchst du für deine
Eltern eine Linux Distribution?
Warum nimmst du nicht einfach Ubuntu?
Oder Mint?
Nimm Linux Mint.
Mint ist doch super für Einsteiger.
Bäm.
Get rekt.
Oh hab ich meinen. Whoa, whoa, what the, what the.
One case. So an das.
Ich wollte gucken ob ich meinen Lootfilter richtig
eingestellt hab. Strict.
Ja passt.
Ein bisschen Scrolls sammeln.
Was hat mich denn hier halb in die
Luft gesprengt gerade?
ETF, was war das denn?
Die machen ja übelst Damage gerade.
Was ist denn hier los?
Aber ich mach auch übelst Damage.
Lul.
Da haben die Gegner
nichts zu lachen hier.
Da hatte ich mal mal gleich.
Warum droppt da hinten jetzt was?
Da ist doch gar nichts mehr.
Oh.
Hallo. NA click.
Da fetzt alles weg.
Excellent. So muss das sein.
Brauche ich nicht.
Hab ich schon alles.
Leute, macht ihr die, macht ihr die Trials
eigentlich auch wenn ihr schon alles habt?
Lohnt sich das überhaupt?
Guck mal hier jetzt gehts, gehts, gehts
gedroppt.
Nein.
Nee. Würde ich auch. Wozu auch?
Ich mein man kann dieses Offering zwar verkaufen
für ein bisschen was, aber die Zeit ist es
gar nicht wert.
Hallo? Verrecken please.
Verrecken plitz.
Oh. Nein. Nein, nein, nein.
Diesmal lasse ich mich nicht von den Jibänen.
Moin, Patrick.
Oh.
Ist aber schon geil,
ist aber schon geil wie die Gegner
einfach, einfach explodieren.
Oh, ich muss die Trials machen.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
One KS. Alter, Alter.
Gehst du fort.
One KS.
Was ist, was machen die für
Damage? Alter.
Lol.
Ok, wir machen einfach Kite Action.
Da können die nämlich überhaupt nichts dagegen machen.
Das ist total, total Noobstyle.
Wenn man keinen Bock hat stehen zu bleiben und zu fighten, man läuft einfach
im Kreis und spammt Feuerbälle auf die
Gegner. Easy. Da können die nämlich überhaupt nichts dagegen
machen.
Ja, naja, mein
Gear ist noch nicht so wahnsinnig gut.
Das hauptsächliche Problem ist aber, dass ich noch einen der
wichtigen Passiv-Skills nicht habe, die man
braucht.
Und mir
auch durch das Gear noch ein paar
Skills fehlen,
dass die auch passiv
funktionieren.
Aber der hat schon echt gerade heftig Damage. Oh, was, was hat's
hier gedroppt?
Eine rote Map.
Loot overkill, please.
Astral Plates sind immer gut,
die verkaufen sich gut.
Äh.
Ja, dann nicht.
Irgendwas Gutes noch dabei.
Ok, das ist doch alles
Müll, oder? Das kann man doch alles
wegschmeißen.
Hey, das Ding ist gerade noch zu übel.
Kann man sogar verkauft.
Increased Fire Damage?
1 bis 4 Lightning
Damage. Wäre das eine ordentliche
Lightning Damage Roll, da wäre das ganz gut gewesen.
Alles Müll hier.
Ah, das taugt doch.
Das taugt doch nichts.
Na gut, so, eine Sache müssen wir noch machen.
Fällt mir gerade ein.
Erstmal
das ganze Loot loswerden.
Müssen noch
Tower Defense spielen.
Müssen noch eine Runde
Defense machen.
Oh, da ist noch was.
Act.
Musst du das machen,
dass die Prophecy weggeht. So.
Und jetzt kannst du wieder raus.
Das hat es jetzt gebracht.
Das habe ich auch noch nicht so 100%
kapiert. Das ist ja so ein Mini
Tower Defense Game. Meistens
ist das easy, aber manchmal
geht dieses Ding in 3, 4,
5 verschiedene Richtungen und du kannst
das gar nicht alles richtig defenden.
Ich glaube, wenn
man das richtig clever macht mit den
Türmen, muss man gar nichts Großartiges
machen. Aber so 100%
kapiert, welche Türme in welcher
Kombi gut sind,
habe ich jetzt noch nicht.
Where the fuck
geht denn das hin?
Was?
Slowen wir es erstmal?
Dann müssen wir gucken, dass es nicht
auf woanders hingeht.
Wo
kommen die nächsten Gegner her? Hier.
Ich habe keinen Plan, was ich hier mache.
Ich mache genug Damage.
Oh, WTF?
Warum kommen jetzt von hier welche?
Was soll denn das? Machen wir mal einen Stun rein.
Stun,
Slow.
Mehr Slow.
Irgendwie
keine Ahnung, sowas da. Das
macht die anderen Türme stärker.
Irgendwie noch Blitz, Turm.
Was denkt ihr an der Parla an von?
Easy, okay.
Wie gesagt, meistens geht es einfach.
Aber manchmal
ist es überhaupt nicht gebacken,
wenn es aus zu vielen Richtungen kommt.
Ich brauche unbedingt ein paar Scrolls.
Dann zeige ich mal, gab es hier was Gescheites?
Chest.
Next.
Ups.
Oh, die sind viel wert,
die Dinger.
Die sind immer ordentlich was wert.
Oder man macht sie selbst. Die bringen immer richtig was.
Wie kannst du mit mehr als 6k Bitrate streamen?
Das können nicht Partner auch.
Also ich bin Partner,
ja, aber das können nicht Partner auch.
Wenn du nicht Partner bist, dann musst du Glück haben,
dass gerade nicht
zu viel los ist auf Twitch.
Dann musst du dann streamen, 2-3 Mal neu starten.
Und dann
darfst du das auch.
Ist das schon immer so?
Nö, aber schon eine Weile.
Das ist schon
ja,
2 Jahre oder so.
Würde ich mal sagen.
So in einem Dreh.
Oh.
Ich habe leider mal ein Trademark.
Plighted, Burrow, was kriegt
man für so eine Map?
Wie sucht man
eigentlich danach?
Plighted?
Ne.
Und wie heißt das Ding?
Burrow?
Einfach eingeben, oder?
Okay.
Aber wenn man es richtig schreibt.
Äh, ne.
Ich kann nicht schreiben.
Ich bin heute nicht in der Lage zu schreiben.
Aber Plighted.
Hä? Moment.
Ich habe das doch richtig geschrieben.
Der Autocorrected das.
Der Autocorrected.
Ich habe das 2 Mal richtig geschrieben.
Naja, ist doch ganz ordentlich.
Gibt es ein bisschen
was für...
Was?
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Das könnte ich für 25 Chaos reinsetzen.
Ich könnte es auch selbst machen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich
will die nächsten Tage ordentliches Gear
Upgrade machen.
Da könnte ich schon noch so
1-2 Exods
brauchen,
dass ich richtig gutes Gear Upgrade holen kann.
aktuell sieht es bei mir so aus kein exalt am start dafür 208 chaos und ein
bisschen anderen crap glaube ich setze das mal rein
maps so jetzt müssen wir mal da muss gucken dass man nicht gebaited wird
weil es gibt manchmal leute die den kram selbst verkaufen oder besser gesagt
einkaufen wollen und die setzen manchmal für sachen rein viel zu billig dass wenn
die nubs wie ich hier reingucken denken ach das kann man doch für 25 chaos
verkaufen dabei ist es viel mehr wert deswegen muss man immer mal ein bisschen
runter scrollen gucken ob das bei dem auch so ist aber hier scheinen wir mit
25 ganz gut ganz gut hinzukommen
25 teilweise schon drei stunden her 24 ich mache es auch mal für 25 rein ich
will hier upgrade kaufen 25 es ist auch immer ganz guter hinweis für das
übrigens alles crap was ich hier drin habe weiß gar nicht warum ich den ganzen
kram hier reingesetzt habe es alles totaler Müll alles alles gute ist schon
verkauft und der rest ist für 25 chaos ist meistens auch übelst der müll aber
es verkauft sich mit der zeit es ist echt merkwürdig ich setze teilweise die
richtigsten crap items da rein ich habe so einen so den makro laufen mit dem
man gucken kann was die items ungefähr wert sind setzt die rein und der kram
verkauft sich mit der zeit obwohl er totaler müll dabei ist wie viel hast du
in im stash bezahlt das weiß ich nicht aber schon ein bisschen was also ich
habe hier die meisten currency tabs und ich habe glaube sieben
ne sechs quad stash also diese fetten tabs was ist das hier
ach guck mal chaos ob so wunderbar kann man den kram kurz abholen
hier body armor das ist doch immer kleiner crap den braucht keiner und wie
viel zeit ich habe weiß ich nicht wo sieht man das über alle charaktere
zusammen kann man das irgendwo sehen steam ich habe es nicht über steam ich
habe ich habe das nicht über steam ich wollte jetzt machen genau den kram
wo kommen wir das train hier über der glaubt da kommen ja
pass auf da kommt totaler krab raus jetzt moin bar was baba lehmann pass auf und
hätte das noch live hätte das live wäre das ganz gut hat es aber nicht
poggers krab
so was machen wir als nächstes für eine wir gucken jetzt erstmal nach einer
kamera auf aliexpress haben wir noch eine andere rote ich bin übelst kaputt nach
dem dacht dem nach dem tür zusammenbau ne krasse kript da machen wir das ich
bin total im arsch ich weiß gar nicht warum ich das so anstrengend finde im
prinzip habe ich gemacht ein paar paar sachen durchgeschnitten mit mit dem
dremel und es hat zweieinhalb stunden gedauert das war eigentlich nichts nix
mit voll kaputt was willst mit einer kamera ich will wieder
der kamera in hof setzen die kein reflect please ok keine reflect excellent
mal ja kommt da was gutes bei raus physikal reflect ist mir egal ok kein
kein magic reflect excellent da bin das immer dabei meine kamera ist
doch kaputt gegangen hier da habe ich doch so ein ich hatte so ein fünfer pack
bestellt und ich habe zwar noch welche aber ich fürchte es geht wieder kaputt
für den hof die sind halt nicht für outdoor gedacht wie gesagt ich hatte da
so was zum drüber ziehen so ein kamerakondom aber das hat nicht allzu
gut geholfen das ging jetzt ein jahr oder so ungefähr über den daumen
gepfeilt und ich brauche ordentliche outdoor kamera und wenn man was sucht
das ist alles entweder übertrieben teuer und china kram oder aber übertrieben
teuer ohne normale stützstellen also ich brauche ganz normal rtsp stream und gut
ist also wie gesagt entweder ist es wenn es
bei amazon.de kauf entweder ist es viel zu teurer china kram oder leute 20 euro
china cams für 200 euro verkaufen also was ich brauche im endeffekt für die
kamera ist folgendes ich brauche eine kamera die infrarot leds hat für
nacht sicht und halt wasserdicht ist und halt ein rtsp stream also und im
prinzip war es das mir brauche ich nicht willst du wieder die bahn stream das
geht ja gerade nicht ich spiele ja nicht die bahn man sieht ein stück von der
bahn im kamerawinkel ja die machen glaube ich übelst damage die mobs ja
das ist weil also kaufen kann man sich die dinger in deutschland in ich beide
sind viel zu teuer guck mal hier das kostet 35 dollar und sogar schon viel zu
teuer ich brauche eine ich habe letztens ich habe letztens ein gutes video gesehen
von ihm hier zum thema kameras ja ja und da wollte ich mir eigentlich die eine
kamera kaufen genau aber genau das ding aber nee das war das nicht
aber an der hat mir irgendwas nicht gefallen
irgendwas genau genau das ist keine wlan kamera
ich habe kein lahn kabel an der stelle wo im flur die kameras hängen
das schreit nach einem youtube video kommentar zum ab flexen
ja genau ich will eine wlan ich will eine wehle stimmt das habe ich ganz
vergessen ich will eine wlan kamera weil wie gesagt ohne wlan ist halt ein
bisschen doof weil ich da auf der wille was was kaufen von mir guck mal da
exzellent exzellent exzellent in weit ja mani mani
äh hä? soll ich mich verarschen? guck mal ich
invite ihn einfach noch mal vielleicht hat er sich verklickt
scammed skamars oder ok da hat kein bock
ja gut dann halt nicht ja machst du nix
25 weiß nicht was er für schmerzen hat ach so der ingame chat ich lasse
ich lasse den ingame chat an ist mir egal der ist teilweise ganz lustig zum
größten teil übelst cancer toxic ingame ingame chat bullshit ja ok anscheinend
hat er keinen bock der will es nicht kaufen na gut
dann halt nicht ne ich habe ich nicht noch eine karte für wisdom wisdom scrolls
exzellent haben wir noch ein paar perfekt hol mal klar mal schnell die olle könnte ich
auch mal hier an start holen runter wisdom scrolls wisdom scrolls exzellent
haben wir wieder sind wir wieder extrem weise für heute
ist quasi 11 hätte aber wenn er jetzt schon einer geschrieben hat dann wird
auch kleiner dann noch noch mal schreiben ja und das ist die sache die ich brauche
ich brauche ich brauche eine wlan kamera und bei diesem test hier
warum bin ich so im arsch von zwei in zweieinhalb stunden tor bauen gibt es
doch nicht ist halt das problem ich fand alles ich fand das richtig gut wie er
das hier getestet hat aber es ist halt keine wlan kamera sowas ich brauche ich
kann sie aber kamer zu ein geben ich brauche eine wlan outdoor kamera kamera
und halt eine die ertsp kann und am liebsten und am liebsten nicht so eine
sondern eine daum kamera wo man wo man übers web interface den winkel
verstellen kann so und alles was ich finde sind solche mega fetten teuren
dinger ich meine da bricht mit das bricht mir
halb von der wand ab so fett ist das
und hier gibt es da nix und das kann doch nicht sein
es gibt kameras wie sand am mehr wie kann das sein dass ich da nix finde
okay hat keiner geschrieben
der in game chat
eine minuten abos face reveal ja so sieht es aus
guck mal diese mega fetten kackdinger das will ich mir nicht an die wand hängen
ich will ich will so eine kleine dome camera die wlan hat die für ein
outdoorbetrieb gedacht ist sowas hier sowas hier so und was ich da dran zu
meckern habe ist also erstens ich finde ich finde dazu nix großartiges und das
nächste okay wie versorgt man das ding hier mit strom so das what the fuck
gebeck und das nächste ist dass wie ver fack was wollte ich jetzt sagen
haben die ntsp
denke mal eine million abos hätte er mittlerweile wenn er so aktiv wie früher
wäre ich glaube nicht aber aber ich hätte auf jeden fall definitiv deutlich
mehr abos wenn ich so aktiv wäre wie früher ich war ja wenn man es mal so
sieht ich war ja auf youtube wirklich aktiv vielleicht vier jahre 2010 11 12
13 14
15 hat schon abgenommen
und dann immer mal wieder zwischendurch relativ aktiv aber nie aber nie so
richtig das liegt aber auch einfach daran weil
mir youtube auf dem keks geht mir geht youtube auf dem keks mir geht so ein
bisschen
weiß ich mir geht es auch so ein bisschen die der content den ich mache was sind
das
schlecht ich habe aktuell nicht so wirklich die
großartigen content-ideen ich meine ja ich habe einen riesen ich habe einen
riesen textdokument wo ich ideen drin stehen habe aber ich bräuchte halt so
was wo sich auch ein paar sachen von alleine ergeben kann ja nicht sein dass
ich mir quasi für jedes video also wenn ich wirklich regelmäßig videos machen
möchte dann heißt das ja auch keine ahnung sei
immer 23 die woche was jetzt wieder für den damage was hier los dass ich mir
dafür jedes video irgendwie übelst das gehirn verbiegen muss das heißt im
endeffekt ich brauche wieder den game was man ordentlich suchen kann was
youtube interessiert und was was ist wozu ich was sagen kann ja und wo ich auch
gut drinne bin also also zum beispiel neues battle viel oder so
ich meine ich bin weit davon entfernt irgendwie so gut bettel viel zu spielen
wie keine hexe oder so ich bin ganz ok im battlefield sieht man ja auch wenn ich
mal wieder wenn ich mal wieder anmache ich bin ja schon ganz gut drinne und ich
komme da auch ich komme da auch immer gut rein das problem ist dass mir die
neuen bettel viel seit absolut kein bau machen
und modern warfare macht mir meine güde macht mir multiplayer halt überhaupt
kein spaß das einzige was erträglich ist is war zone die mache aber damage
heute what the fuck monka extrem muss unbedingt hier upgraden ich halte viel ich
brauche ich brauche eine autocast wand also autocast zauberstab
durch das man ist nicht normales für den damage machen
aber mein defense also was ich als defense skill unbedingt brauche ist das
hier das da da brauche ich noch zwei skill points für oder ich skill oder
einen ich kann hier oben noch mal kurz live wegskillen
ich brauche auf jeden fall also ich habe ich habe absolutes müll hier muss man
dazu sagen das einzige was ich habe ist halt ziemlich gute chest selbst gelingt
ich zeig euch mal also einzige was ich habe ich habe mit die beste chest die
man im game bekommen kann für den speck selbst gelingt mit den passenden
sockets und alles kannst du locker für fünf exhalts verkaufen gerade also das
habe ich der rest ist dreck der rest ist kompletter müll
guckt euch mal an der rest ist das amu das amu geht noch halbwegs ja das amu ist
noch es macht fire damage bis in decks und hat cold das amu ist ist auch noch
ganz ok aber der rest ist müll guckt euch mal das schild an das ist das hat
nix so guckt euch den zauberstab an der hat auch nix das ist absoluter crap
guckt euch die handschuhe an auch totaler müll der gürtel geht zumindest
vom live her ist aber auch ziemlich dreck die schuhe das einzige was die
haben sind 30 prozent increased movement movement speed auch müll ja flasks
habe ich auch nix gutes die einzig gute flasche ich habe sind die zwei die zwei
hier mit pleading remove und instant recovery also das gear ist wirklich
crap und ich mein dafür bürste ich trotzdem alles weg so aber das liegt
halt auch an der chest die chest ist eigentlich das beste weil ich hab
warum habe ich das bräuchte die chest ist das hat zu wenig energie und ich
habe genug währung ich habe bestimmt also wenn ich mal mit dem ganzen kram
verkaufen würde der auch der will was kaufen da war mir das doch jetzt mal
ex-crap man exzellent was hört auf mich zu beden was ist mit den los
die schrei mich immer an haben will kaufen nein doch nicht
what the fuck die soll man nicht auf den sack hin die sollen den kram einfach kaufen
scam ja wie soll er mich scam er hat ja nichts davon so und wie gesagt ich habe
genug an das ist ja mal ich habe genug currency um richtig krasses gear upgrade
zu machen wenn ich meine ganzen kram ich habe richtig viele essenzen die die die
meta essenzen da die ich die ich verkaufen kann
ich habe irgendwelche upgrade frag mich nicht crafting sachen also ich könnte
bestimmt wenn ich den ganzen kram verkaufe kriege ich bestimmt noch mal
zwei drei ex als raus von dem was ich jetzt habe
muss ich halt mal mich hinsetzen und den ganzen das entmüllen so und ich bin so
ultra faul in dem game auch wie in echt ich grinde einfach nur und mach mit dem
gier nix also ich mach mach mit dem mit dem was ich er kreide nix
dabei könnte ich könnte ultra fettes gear upgrade machen ich meine ist ja nicht
so als wäre damage der damage jetzt das problem damage ist guckt euch mal einmal
geklickt alles tot bähm am damage scheitert nicht hier guckt sagt bähm
kaputt next sagt kaputt also am damage liegt nicht ich
brauche auf jeden fall mein defense skill und mehr leben mehr leben ein
bisschen energy shield und auf jeden fall und das ist eigentlich das wo ich
als nächstes danach gucken muss eine gescheite entweder neues amulett mit
life leech und feier oder also und auf jeden fall einen neuen zauberstab
neun in neun wand
dann sieht die ganze sache schon viel besser aus ich mein kaputt gehen die
gegner instant ich glaube reintrücken knopf gegner tot bähm
er ist ein eigenes bild ok ja so big brain bin ich noch nicht für eigene
bilds ich nehme immer sachen von denen ich weiß dass sie funktionieren
oder oder geht aber gut ab hier
da hält aber ganz schön aus der gute das ist halt auch kein boss kill boss
kill speck
piss dich alle dauerung wow loot explosion da gibt es noch ein paar
identifizierung scrolls
immer noch home office ja immer noch home office
strand map so viel so viel strand ok gucken wir mal wie die strand map
kreieren können ja schon schon mal nicht schlecht oder kann fast ganz gut das
rauskommen
gucken wir mal für die abgekradet kriegen die andere auch
blies kein elemental reflect kein elemental reflect
ja eigene bild sind meistens wenn man also ist im prinzipie an allen games so
wenn man keine ahnung hat gerade in so komplexen gelben wie pass auf exalt
vergibt man sich weide wei gibt vergibt man sich habt ihr mitgekriegt dass gimp
sich von der weile gefolgt hat weil die leute den namen anstößig fanden
ok da ist kein elemental reflect dabei wenn ich das richtig sehe ja ist total
hängen geblieben da total hängen geblieben
man kann sich auch über alles aufregen
aber das ist ja das ist ja der job der menschheit gerade sich über alles
aufzuregen beim vor ging es aber um mehr also das ist das was ich mit der kopf
habe dass die sich hauptsächlich am namen aufgehängt haben dass sie nicht
gefällt excellent aber es wie gesagt es sind ja es sind ja hobb es ist ja so das
hobby von vielen sich einfach einfach sinnlos über alles aufzuregen und zu
empören jetzt haben sie inne wobei ich da disclaimer sagen muss ich habe das
nicht weiter verfolgt weil ich verfolge keine twitterdiskussion mehr das geht
mir einfach nur auf den keks also ich habe hier meine twitter trends jetzt wie gesagt auf
andorra umgestellt weil ich keinen bock mehr habe auf twitter trends in deutschland
ich habe letztes gelesen haben irgendeine adidas managerin rausgeworfen weil die
sie nicht selbst etwa leute diskriminiert hat oder oder irgendwie
runtergemacht hat sondern sie hat glaube ich in einem interview oder
irgendwo gesagt sie glaubt nicht dass rassismus ein eine große rolle spielt
oder irgendwie großartig präsent ist bei bei adidas instant kick also es reicht
heute schon dass das wirklich dass das einfach nur irgendwas zu sagen was
triggert und du bist ein job los
also ich bin der meinung man sollte die zwei autos dahinten man sollte das
prinzipiell voneinander trennen die leute sollen sich doch schon noch so
äußern können wie sie wollen ob es jetzt gefällt oder nicht
ich bin auch nicht mit allem einverstanden was die leute teilweise so
absondern vor allem nicht im internet aber deswegen wünsche ich trotzdem
kein dass er seinen job verliert weil er irgendwas im internet geschrieben hat
oh nee das sind wir die gegner die so viel damage machen
monka ist erstmal taum portal aufmachen ich glaube wir machen gleich die
rum kite action ja wir kiten gleich da kann er nichts machen abs absoluter
kacknup wenn er gekijtert wird lull
pass und excel butse all la la la trash and daro
Ups
Einfach weglaufen und da ins Bell drücken
Poggers
So musst du es machen
Hab ich eigentlich alle Gegner gekillt?
Ups
Wo lauf ich denn hin?
Nee, also das kenn ich auch nicht Knäherbär
Ich kenn auch keinen der
professionell Bilder bearbeitet
und das mit Gimp macht
Also, okay, professionell
ist dehnbar, also
der das tagtäglich benutzt
und damit sein Geld verdient
und ich rede jetzt nicht
von einem Webdesigner, sondern wirklich jemand
der mit Bildern und Bild bearbeitet
und sein Geld verdient, sei es ein Fotograf
oder sowas, da
fällt mir echt keiner ein
und ich will nicht bezweifeln
dass es das gibt, aber die sind deutlich
in der Unterzahl
Also, alle meine ehemaligen
Designsour auf YouTube
haben alle gesagt, Gimp ist
an sich ganz nett
aber wenn sie was machen, machen sie es trotzdem
mit Photoshop und Illustrator
Also, da scheint schon was dran zu sein
dass Gimp da keine
vollwertige Alternative ist
Ich muss euch auch sagen, ich hab
persönlich jetzt selbst auch nur ein paar mal benutzt
und was mir halt auf den Keks gegangen ist
ist, dass die
Bedienung irgendwie sehr, ich will nicht
sagen, dass die Photoshop-Bedienung jetzt irgendwie super
den Wahnsinns-Innovationspreis
gewinnen würde oder so, aber
die Gimp-Bedienung war doch
sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig
Mal gucken, ob er mich jetzt, mal gucken, ob er mich
wieder jebaitet
Mal gucken, ob er mich wieder jebaitet
Oh nee, excellent
Der will es wirklich kaufen
Ich glaub's nicht
Lull
GG
Whisper, whisper
T
Paint.net ist auch Poggers
Ja, Paint.net ist
ganz nett um Sachen zu
bearbeiten, aber für Profis eher nix
Also ich muss
sagen, ich komm mit Affinity Designer und Affinity
Foto ganz gut klar
Hauptsächlich Affinity Designer
Das ist so, das ist so für
Kacknoobs bei mir
Also wie Kacknoobs wie ich
ist Affinity Designer ganz gut
Das macht
einen sinnvollen Eindruck von den
Funktionen her, die es kann
Er hätte so ein bisschen live, da wäre das
relativ gut
Aber ich kanns
bedienen im Vergleich zu Photoshop
So
Nächste
Oh, die sieht ein bisschen gefährlicher aus hier
Mal gucken
Für deine nicht existenten YouTube Thumbnails
Genau
Ich hab schon ein paar richtig coole Thumbnails
zwischenzeitlich mal gemacht
Da waren schon ein paar nice Thumbnails
dabei
Die sind jetzt nicht die hohe künstlerische
Barung oder so
Aber die waren schon teilweise echt gut
Also da waren schon ein paar
gute Memes, Memes Sachen dabei
Die Gegner
einfach nur platzen, das ist so geil
So hier Gachi
Bass
Bam, next
Übrigens
Wer gerne
in ein Bild spielen möchte
wo man sieht was passiert
ist das hier nichts
Weil
Naja, also man sieht
halt nichts wie nicht was passiert
Ich kann mal die Microtransactions rausnehmen
Dann seht ihr wie das Bell normalerweise aussieht
Moment, wo kann man
Cosmetics hier
Ja
Ich hab die Micro, so siehts normalerweise aus
Ist auch nicht wirklich besser
Ist eigentlich noch
ist noch mehr Performance
Und man sieht noch weniger was
Kennst du noch den Bild
wo man einfach nur ein helles Licht gesehen und alles geleckt hat
Du meinst dieses Cyclending
was wir letztens hatten
wo der ganze Bildschirm
Regenbogenfarbe war
ein Wide-Bild
Ich glaub das war irgendein Cycleng-Bild
vorletzte oder vorletzte League
Wo es alle gekreiselt haben
Ja, also sag mal so
wenn hier viel los ist
passiert hier auch nicht mehr außer Bildschirm explodiert
sind tot
Also wirklich großartig erkennen
was passiert, tust du hier auch nicht
Also das Bild braucht echt
Epilepsiewarnung
Was ist denn das hier für komische
Spritzer
Oh guck mal da unten ist ein Unic
getroppt
Die Unic sind halt
zum größten Teil Crap
Es gibt ein paar richtig gute
Sag mal
Spuckt das den Gegner aus oder was?
Aber die meisten Unics sind Crap
Pepega Unics
Bebega
Jetzt kommen wieder diese komischen Endgegner
die so viel Damage machen
Was ist denn das hier eigentlich?
Winterheart
Das ist bestimmt nichts wert
wenn es Magic Find drauf hat
Oh guck mal
der tropft einfach mal eine Map
So wir lassen uns gar nicht drauf ein
irgendwie was mit den Gegnern zu machen
Wir machen die Kalten die einfach einmal im Kreis
Man muss nicht verstehen was passiert
Es explodiert einfach der ganze Bildschirm und gut ist
Oh
Der Masler
What the fuck alter
War nicht so ein Damage
Was soll ich so ein Damage machen
Guck mal ich renn weg vor dir, geh weg
Ey hör auf zu Chargen
Was ist hier los?
Aufhören zu Chargen
Nicht Chargen
Wow
Monka
Das war aber knapp
Die machen ein bisschen viel Damage
die Gegner
Aber nur die Bosse
Oh Map
Mach mal ein OnlyFans Account
und poste einfach nur Bilder von IT Zeug
Warum sollte ich das denn machen?
Ich guck trotzdem mal auf die andere Seite
der Map schnell ob da nicht
ob da nicht noch irgendwie
Blight Encounter oder irgendwas ist
geht ja schnell
Oh
Hallo
Obbei ne die Map fängt ja hier an
sieht man ja an der Ecke da kann nix mehr sein
Na gut
Dann war es umsonst hingerennt
Ah erstmal schön desynkt
Excellent
easy money genau
haben wir noch eine rote map
moment ah ja wir haben noch zwei maps sehr gut was ist das hier
temple map machen wir die mal den rest sortieren wir mal in
stash im map stash ein
so gucken wir mal ob wir da was... ah ne die ist schon enchantert elemental bla bla bla okay kein
reflekt das ist schon mal gut
ja ach so ja stimmt ich wollte nach der kamera gucken genau
genau das nächste problem ist dann wie wird der kram mit strom versorgt haben
sie rtsp
und wie werden sie mit strom versorgt
und die sieht halt mega billig aus
ich finde einfach keine gute wlan kamera
die man über kein usb oder so mit strom versorgt
ein dünnes usb kabel kriege ich durchs fenster
ein lancabel habe ich da nicht
ich sag nachtsicht und wlan und outdoor die kombination brauche ich
wireless strom ja laser laser genau
und die sind eigentlich sind die mir auch zu teuer
na power over ether das geht ja nicht ich hab ja kein netzwerkabel da
ohne netzwerkabel
bringt mir power over ether net auch nix
und und
ich gebe keine 230 euro dafür aus die andere hat 35 dollar gekostet
das hier wäre das hier wäre preislich noch was das würde ich mitmachen ja
solar strom
du weißt doch was doch gemacht hat
nee weiß ich nicht
soll ich das wissen
ich habe ich ich habe aber vermutet
was macht eigentlich der sound hier grad
der funktioniert noch
ja und deswegen wollte ich mal bei aliexpress gucken aber ich gucke mal
was es gerade bei china gadgets oder so für für
kamera
so irgendwelche angebote gibt
ich weiß auch nicht was mit mir los ist ich hab früher nie
auf angebote geguckt
jetzt
also wo ich im prinzip
viel mehr geld hat als früher wo ich nicht auf angebote geguckt hab
gucke ich auf einmal nach angeboten ist eigentlich total
bescheuert
blan outdoor rtsp
camera
das andere lassen wir mal auf wollte ich mal gucken was sie da sonst noch empfehlen
siehst du das sind nämlich die eigentliche preise von den dingern
diese zachen
die hier bei aliexpress
40 40 euro kosten
verkaufen manche manche typen dann auf amazon die e
für
200 oder sowas
man guckt euch mal die namen an
kennt keiner kennt keiner kennt keiner
nun im zoll 270
das muss ja schon vergoldet sein dass ich das lohnt
das ist alles der gleiche mist
ich weiß was ich machen könnte ist
ich könnte
exes point
in die kirche stellen
und vom exes point an
kabel also pack per per
lan kabel
per letzwerd kabel
durchs fenster an die kamera
aber wozu wenn ich einfach eine wlan kamera holen kann
hol eine kamera mit 5g damit die bänchen vor der tür demonstrieren
genau kameraden funken hast
ich kauf mir einfach einen funken hast und macht da die kamera dran
was hält davon
dann lohnt sich wenigstens ohne 250 euro kamera
ich mache mir einen 4 5g funken hast
aufs dach und da die kamera dran
so also das hat doch hier schon mal ganz gut anwalt ist das
die feier kameraden viermal digital zoom zoom ist mir ziemlich egal
hat 265 ok brauche ich brauche auf jeden fall hat 264
nein das
das ist nicht wie digital zoom funktioniert
digital zoom ist das was man in paint auch macht also
man kriegt nicht auf einmal mehr details da irgendwie rein die man vorher nicht
gesehen hat oder so
ich will mit der kamera nicht sprechen
will einfach dass die kamera mit bilder vom hof anzeigt
color night vision
das sind einfach
das sind einfach leds
die die umgebung hell machen
das hat das mit color night vision zu tun
der macht einfach hell dann ist es kein night mehr
EU stecker
was was denn für stecker überhaupt
was was kommt überhaupt für stecker rein
das das haut ich ja weg
das steht was mit klaut das muss über tsp funktionieren wenn das nicht über
tsp funktioniert
ok was was ist der strom was für ein strom stecker
was ist das für ein komischer strom stecker das ist doch auch das ist doch
auch da kommt doch auch in den rj 45 stecker rein
der hat ja das machen viele china anbietern über das qr-code-scan
also sprich der zeigt eine qr-code auf dem handy an und hält die kamera dann das
in die kamera dann konfiguriert sich die kamera über den qr-code
das ist eigentlich ziemlich big brain
also ich finde deswegen sage ich ja das ding muss rtsp können
und das kann wahrscheinlich rtsp
also wenn es on 5 kann ganz wahrscheinlich rtsp
ohne rtsp ist
und usable
witzke wie
witz was ist das für den namen alter
das ist eigentlich was russisches
witzkrieft
oder so
das kann doch keiner aussprechen
da fehlen viele vokale ich meine die haben zwei i's drin da ist ja schon mal was
das war es aber auch
keine ahnung was für den kram wieder los ist
guck mal bald haben wir level up wenn ich nicht verrecke
so und
ansonsten es gibt es ist aber es muss es gibt millionen kameras
es kann doch nicht sein dass da keine dabei ist
limited offer ok was ist das für ein billig kram
das muss ganz schön schwer sein wenn ich das mit drei schrauben an die wand
befestigen muss
mag die maps nicht die
die slowdown
heute ich mache mal die microtransaktions wieder rein
das nervt mich
dass ich
dass ich da feuerbälle seh die rot sind
ich will keine roten feuerbälle
da
schwarze feuerbälle
zu lull
40 euro das wegen sage ich ja
dass es sich überhaupt nicht lohnt den kram beamert ja auf auf auf
du kommst da drüber
deswegen sage ich es lohnt sich überhaupt nicht so was bei amazon.de zu
kaufen
weil amazon.de verkauft den gleichen china krab
nur für 200 euro
ok machen wir gleich den boss
aber der kann ich sehen kann ich das sagt
der sagt richtig der kriegt gar nichts gebacken
vielleicht ein bisschen ausweichen kann ich schon noch
gachi bus boss der sagt richtig der kriegt gar nichts gebacken hier guck mal
wie schlecht er ist
noob boss
omega noob
ein fauler staff
ich bin zu faul die die 6 sockets für orbs aufzuheben
komm jetzt mal in richtig
richtig hütsch hütsch big brain
op drop
muss auch gar nicht für mich sein irgendwas was man gut verkaufen kann
dann mache ich morgen nehme ich wirklich ordentlich gear upgrade
wenn ich hab genug kohle
aber für gear upgrade man kann nie genug kohle haben
und ich muss meinen harvestgarten unbedingt ausbauen
der sieht ja kümmerlich aus im vergleich zu dem was ich bei manchen
streamer sehe
die übertreiben es richtig eh
die bauen ihren garten aus der ist der ist
5 fußballfelder groß
und also wir wissen ja in deutschland messen muss man alles was großes wird in
fußballfelder gemessen
und
haben
storage tanks
50 irgendwelche
craft speicher station und sonst was da blicke ich nicht durch
ich weiß gar nicht
im chat sehe facebook live streams
wir haben uns das ja letztens im stream mal angeguckt
und ich ich habe es jetzt noch mal ohne ohne den den chat
dabei angeschaut mal in hohe facebook facebook gaming stream
die seite ist richtig kacke
wer das wirklich ernsthaft als twitch twitch konkurrent sieht der ist nicht
der ist entweder
boomer facebook fan
der quasi facebook immer noch für den neuesten shit im internet hält
oder er hat noch nie was ordentliches benutzt und weiß
wie sich eine gute seite anfühlt
richtig schlecht
ja mlg tv haben sie auch mal probiert
äh wie ist die map schon mal fertig
das war jetzt aber eine kurze map
war ja gar nichts drauf
ja mlg tv hat es auch mal probiert konkurrenz zu machen aber das
was mir ja fehlt bei allen anderen dieser twitch konkurrenten
ist so doof es klingt der twitch chat
weil was wäre ein chat ohne die sinnlosen ganzen twitch emotes
ohne twitch emotes ist livestream nur noch halb so gut
also erstmal
ohne ordentlichen chat und ohne ordentlich emotes
und das müssen halt twitch emotes sein
sind die twitch emotes eigentlich copyrighted ja definitiv also
jaja klar deswegen
konnten die auch nicht das originale lul emote verwenden weil der fotograf noch rechte hatte
das kannst du nicht einfach auf einer anderen seite verwenden
was man allerdings machen könnte
ist
man müsste von anfang an die community mit ins bot holen bzw die plugin entwickler
also ich könnte mir vorstellen wenn man es irgendwie schafft
die better twitch tv app und ffz app browser extension
so mit ins bot zu holen vielleicht auch die entwickler zu bezahlen dass sie das machen
dass sie einen neuen streaming service mit unterstützen
weil dort an den emotes hat twitch ja keine rechte
und das sind auch trittanbieter emotes was twitch twitch nicht juckt
klar die meisten leute gucken mobile und haben kein better twitch tv oder sonst was
aber das wäre zumindest schon mal eine art und weise wie man so sachen wie
angefangen keine ahnung angefangen von irgendwie
pepega bis pepehands kogas pogas sonst was
das sind ja alles keine twitch emotes aber schon quasi aufgestiegen zu fast echten twitch
emotes ja easy und alle möglichen sachen
ist die monka s alle sachen die es gibt es gibt ja kaum den emote was vor allem für
entfällt wie monka s und es ist kein offizielles twitch emote
das könnte man machen also wenn man die von anfang an unterstützt
zu sehen wieviel prozent an der zuschau auf mobile gucken ich weiß es nicht ich
gucke mir ich gucke mir twitch statistik nie an
ich gucke mir nie twitch statistics an weiß ich nicht
noch mal das gleiche ok auf geht's
so erstmal erst mal rng brain plus rng darf man nicht mehr machen dass kein reflect kommt
und ob kein reflect und jetzt korrupten wir das ding klar noch mal und hoffen
dass wieder kein reflect kommt es kommt wieder kein reflect und das ist
exzellent ich bräuchte habe ich eigentlich noch kato kreffer
kato kreffer wie heiße die dinger da die da die brauche ich ja kann map
qualität verbessern hätte ich vorher noch machen sollen
so nachdem wir level ab haben machen wir noch den boss steams zu dieses xbox event
oh zeig mal her zeige mal xbox games showcase 23 juli das ist ja noch ewig hin
wieviel uhr leute schreibt eine zeitzone dabei dann ist das so schwer nicht jeder wohnt in
den usa
da steht eine zeitzone pacific time ich hab nix gesagt 18 Uhr montags ok
ja mach ich mach ich das schreibe ich mir gleich mal auf wann habe ich gerade 18 uhr
18 uhr
wo hatten wir das jetzt events hatten wir das reingeschrieben
gleich 18 uhr cst ja streame ich wenn man es wenn man es streben darf aber meistens
darf man es streben was ist das
das ist eine fucking xbox sandburg warum ok die sind dedicated
also wie man xbox noch so hart fanboyen kann nach der letzten generation verstehe ich
war ja übelst der xbox fanboy zur 360 zeit
please warum warum sehe ich deutschland trends
muss das denn sein laura und der wendler oh gott
datzen was ist datzen
hat irgendjemand eine ahnung was datzen ist
datzen ist sportstreaming futz ok das juckt mich überhaupt nicht
fußball alter
busfahrer führerschein
handkündigung verwaltung immunsystem testen
was alles war wieder trendet
ich traue mich in deutschland gar nicht mehr auf die trends zu klicken
weil dann immer irgendwas dahinter sich verbirgt wo man sich aufregen muss
das ist wahrscheinlich von irgendwelchen anti corona leuten die wieder rum holen
dass sie geistig am ende sind wegen corona und die umwelt ist ja ist ja nicht zu ertragen
mehr seit corona
deswegen habe ich und das geht aber noch es ist wirklich verhältnismäßig zahm hier
gerade an twitter trends ja
deswegen habe ich meinen twitter auf andorra umgestellt ich will diesen ganzen bullshit
aus deutschland einfach gar nicht mehr sehen
ops wo habe ich die map hin
wo wo wo wo habe ich meine
ah ich habe die map schon aufgemacht
du kannst sagen wo ist meine map in mocha s
get schreckt
bämbämbämbämbämbämbämbämbä specialty
Aua, äh, pass auf, wir machen jetzt Big Brain, Switch, BAM, schon sind wir drüben.
15 head. Was, warum sagst du eigentlich die ganze Zeit Arschloch auf Niederländisch?
Ich kann kein Niederländisch. Ich kann nur ein Wort auf Niederländisch und das ist Monkathos.
Ich glaub ich hab's euch schon mal erzählt, welches. Vielleicht erinnert sich noch der
ein oder andere. Natürlich ist es eine Beleidigung, weil das erste was man in
anderen Sprachen lernt sind selbstverständlich Beleidigungen.
Aber das ist Monkathos, Monkathos-Level-Beleidigungen auf Niederländisch,
die ich kann. Das einzige niederländische Wort. Ich weiß gar nicht warum ich das eigentlich
kenne. Also egal, das ist ja nicht verboten. Also das einzige niederländische Wort ist
Ziegenficker auf Niederländisch. Das einzige was ich sagen kann. Ich weiß gar nicht warum,
ehrlich gesagt. Ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern, warum ich weiß, was Ziegenficker
auf Niederländisch heißt. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß total random jetzt, aber aus irgendwelchen
Gründen weiß ich, was es auf Niederländisch heißt. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. Monkathos.
Zum Glück sind wir nicht in Hardcore. Kappa HD. Jetzt haben wir schön viel XP verloren.
Das sagt es. Guck mal, wie viel XP haben wir jetzt? Leute, habt ihr geguckt, wie viel XP
haben wir verloren? Zwei in Balken. Oh, irgendwie so. Zwei in Balken. Die machen
reale Damage hier, die Jungs. Die machen echt Damage. Oh, eine rote Map. Oh, eine schöne
Map. Endlich mal was anderes. Die machen wir gleich hinterher. Oh, die haben uns eben
echt zerrissen, die Gegner. Unbedingt Gear Upgrade. Könntest du mal bitte Death in Global
eingeben? Oh, da habe ich einige, ja. 64, easy. Also ich bin kein Hardcore, also ich
bin nicht für Hardcore geeignet. Wow. Okay, ich muss ein paar Mechanics machen, wie es
aussieht. 64, das ist doch eigentlich für ein Informatiker die beste Zahl. Das heißt,
ab jetzt Hardcore. Ab jetzt wird niemals gestorben. War nicht so übel. Ich kenne mich auch mit
Bow-Stats nicht aus. Bist du schon über 80 mal gestorben? Ja, ist Softcore. Das einzige
Dumme ist, ab einem gewissen Level, wenn man stirbt, das kostet zu viel XP. Das sagt. Ansonsten
ist es eigentlich ziemlich egal. Moment. Was habe ich denn hier gerade? Habe ich eine rote
Map? Ah. Komm mal, wir haben doppelte, eine ordentlich doppelte Map. Kein Reflekt, please,
kein Reflekt. Kein Reflekt. Oh, das ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht, das ist exzellent. Ah,
komm mal, wir haben eine rote Syndicate. Nee, das war mal nicht. Auch mal zu viel Damage.
Ist das Troll? Oh. Oh, what? Was ist denn jetzt los? Oh, haben die Elemental Reflekt und ich
habe es übersehen? What the fuck? Haben die Elemental Reflekt und ich habe es irgendwie
übersehen? Das wäre schlecht. Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was ich checken kann, was die
aktuelle Map, die offen ist, für Modifier hat? Der Chat ist wirklich pepega. Ok, wie?
Ok, warte. Pewe. Sieht man das irgendwo? Current? Sieht man das irgendwo? Hm. Ok,
hm. Wie sieht man, was die aktuelle Map für Modifier hat? Ich belehme mir ein, die hatte
kein Elemental Reflekt. Rechts oben auf den Pfeil drücken. Ah, nee. Was hat mich denn
so schnell gekillt, wenn die keinen Reflekt haben? What the fuck? Was war das denn bitte
schon gerade? Unidentified? Heißt das, du siehst die Mods nicht? Ok, das ist schlecht.
Also sprich, das könnte Reflekt haben. Ok, das hat Reflekt. Das hat Reflekt, so viel
Damage, wie die machen. Ich kann keine Reflektmaps machen, das suckt. Grip. Kacke. Yep, cock,
genau. Das ist ja doof. Das hat gerade Ultra Damage reingedrückt. WTF? Hätte ich mal
lieber verkaufen sollen. Na gut, Peter bist du immer schlauer. Wo kommen wir an der Metamorph
Map? Ok, hier platzen sie wenigstens schön schnell. Also einen Skillpoint brauche ich
noch. Dann kann ich mein Defense Note specken. Weil es natürlich dumm ist, weil jetzt habe
ich wieder so viel XP verloren, also muss ich mir noch 5 Maps cryen, bis ich wieder
die XP aufgeholt habe. Na zumindest, wenn ich den Defense Kram gespeckt habe, dann
soll es besser sein. Und wie gesagt, ich brauche Lifegear. Lifegear und auf jeden Fall einen
Zauberstab, der castet, der automatisch einen Spell auslöst. Egal. Das Schlimmste wäre
jetzt, wenn wir Hardcore wären, weil dann wäre RIP. Aber ich spiele keine Hardcore.
Ich habe schon in Diablo 2 kein Hardcore gespielt. Weiß nicht, ich mag in solchen Spielen irgendwie
kein Hardcore. Und ich meine es ist nicht Gachibas Hardcore. Ich habe Schiss vor dem. Was sind
das hier für ein Endgegner? Der macht bestimmt wieder mega Damage der Endgegner, oder? What
the fuck? Alter. Okay. Und Tschüss. Und Tschüss. Wie kommt man hier wieder raus? Hat das hier
irgendwie einen Ausgang oder so? Moment, das hat keinen Ausgang, das ist Sackt. Die restliche
Map würde ich schon noch gerne machen. Ach nee, die können ja gar nichts. Da kann doch
nix. Wow. What the fuck, Alter. Yep, Cock. Warum haben die so einen Schaden da? Da unten
ist was gedroppt. Davon kann man nicht genug haben. Bin immer wieder begeistert, wie groß
manche Maps sind, obwohl die ja am Anfang gar nicht so aussehen. Kilometer Morph machen
wir hier nicht. Ich will nicht nochmal XP verlieren, weil nach dem nächsten Level Up
kann ich Defense skillen und morgen mache ich Gear Upgrade. Genug Currency, Hammer. Aber
ein Level Up muss noch, ja. Okay, wir machen auf und Jumpen gleich weg. Man weiß ja nie,
was da auch von zukommt. Was ist ein Metamorph? Das zeige ich dir gleich, aber wir machen
nicht. Auf diesen Maps hier, diesen Metamorph Maps, du siehst ja manchmal hier auf der
Übersichtskarte so Gegnergruppen, die so ein grünes Ding haben und die droppen quasi
die Teile. Hier guck da, das grüne. Der hat jetzt ein Auge gedroppt und dieses Auge kann
ich dann quasi später einsetzen und daraus den Boss craften. Der übelst gute Sachen
droppt oder viele Sachen droppt, aber da ziemlich viel Damage macht. Wir können es ja mal ausprobieren.
Dann geht man hier hin und sagt, okay, was für einen Boss will ich haben? Keine Ahnung,
das da. Additional Armor. Additional Armor brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht. Am liebsten
mache ich die Sachen, die Currencies droppen. Wenn man sich jetzt hier zusammen baut, kann
man sich die verschiedenen Sachen raussuchen, weil das ist eigentlich besser. Was der Boss
können soll und dann spawnt der Boss und dann macht der Boss übertrieben Damage und
One-Hitted einen, wenn man nicht aufpasst. Ich kriege den Boss noch nicht mal angeklickt
gerade. Oh nee, der ist fast tot. Muss aber abhauen. Muss den gerade ein bisschen kiten,
weil ich nichts aushalte. Okay, easy. Er droppt halt richtig viel Zeug. Diesmal hältst
ihn Grenzen, aber der droppt meistens richtig viel Zeug. Das war in der vorletzten League
die Hauptmechanik. Da war auf jeder Map so ein Ding. Wie gesagt, vorletzte League, weil
letzte League habe ich nicht gespielt. Übelster Craft hier, guckt euch das mal an. Aber das
anwählen war, da gibt es Crafting Sachen für... Wo ist er denn? Da. Cold and Chaos Resistance
ist immer das wichtigste. Wenn das Ding an sich ist kacke. Ob das was taugt, habe ich
keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Hatte ich gerade gesagt, very nice. Hatten wir jetzt
noch eine ordentliche rote Map oder nicht? Pass of Exile 2 soll doch auch irgendwann
kommen. Ja, ich glaube mal eher nächstes Jahr. An dieses Jahr glaube ich ja nicht mehr.
Man muss ja sagen Pass of Exile 2, das ist so ein bisschen wie Overwatch 2 vom Namen her.
Es ist im Prinzip Pass of Exile 1 mit neuer Kampagne und veränderten Mechaniken. Das Endgame
wird das gleiche sein und Pass of Exile 1, die Kampagne ist auch immer noch drinne. Genau,
das kommt, das ist alles in einem Spiel. Wie lange spielst du schon an Pass of Exile?
Leider der Account ist von 2013. Richtig angefangen habe ich vorletzte Liga erst wieder und letzte
Liga habe ich nicht gespielt. Also das ist im Prinzip mein zweiter Charakter, seit ich
mich wieder angefangen habe. Ich habe halt ein bisschen Theoriecraft gelesen. Hab keine
guten Maps mehr. Bei dem Stash, doch das ist ganz einfach. Das ist alles Crap. Das muss
ich aufräumen. Ich droppe immer alles was ich beim Kreisel-Kreiten kriege. Das können
wir übrigens mal zellen und das können wir auch zellen. Machen wir mal ein bisschen
Platz. Die ganzen Unix kann ich jetzt nicht nachgucken ob die was bringen, aber das sagt.
Alles Müll, alles weg. Genau, ich dump das immer alles da rein und räume das dann irgendwann
mal auf. Also wenn ich zwei Stash-Tabs ungefähr voll habe, dann räume ich einmal auf. Das
geht auch recht easy. Einfach hier nach Currency suchen, alles einsortieren und den Rest verkaufen.
Vielleicht das ein oder andere Item zellen. Gucken. Irgendwie sind die, das habe ich keine
ordentlichen Maps mehr. Was mache ich jetzt? Kaufen. Oder machen wir so eine Lookout. Monsters
Physical Damage Reduction, ja perfekt. Ok, das dürfte easy sein die Map. Hier habe
ich noch ein gelbe, irgendwie ein schönes gelbes Ding hier. Gelben Auftrag. Die Map dürfte
einigermaßen easy sein. Ja ich bin für rote Maps noch ein bisschen andergierend. Der Damage
ist fein, also der Damage ist super, aber Survival Ability ist so ein bisschen problematisch.
Übrigens falls einer von euch irgendwie so eine Trial braucht, kann ich euch hinweiten.
Da sucht man ja meistens richtig lange danach. Eigentlich müsste ich gar nicht so oft casten,
die Feuerbälle machen das quasi Auto-Aim von alleine. Einfach hier ein paar mal gecastet.
So, das reicht schon. Und jetzt fliegen die Feuerbälle hier von alleine rum und bashen
alles. Eigentlich müsste ich gar nicht so viel casten. Nein, was will ich denn da? Ich
kann das nicht. Ach guck mal. Der Damage ist fein, ja der Damage ist wirklich mehr als ok,
aber den Damage kann man sich nicht beschweren. Hast du mal Binding of Isaac gespielt? Ja.
Das macht Spaß, aber das ist auch ein Game, wo glaube ich richtig davon profitiert, weil
man sich da ein bisschen reingrindet. Dass man die ganzen Items kennt. Der Chat ist in
Deutsch, weil ich aus Gründen, die sich mir gerade nicht erschließen, im deutschen Global
Chat bin. Obwohl man klein auf Englisch eingestellt ist. Auch nicht warum. So, wo gehts hin? Oh,
ok. Da. Machen wir mal irgendwie. Die müssen alle vorbei. Ok, ein Slowdown hier hin. Power
Ding dahin, ein Summon Ding dahin. Und den upgraden wir. It's branching. Ppega branching.
Ja, so ist easy, so kann ich einfach in eine Richtung schießen und es passiert nix. Exzellent.
Oh, oh Moment, es ist jetzt nach oben gebrannt, kann das sein? Das ist schlecht. Stun, freeze.
Ok, dann baller ich einfach hier hin. Hier alles weg machen, da alles weg machen, da
unten alles weg machen. Leute, macht euch nix draus, dass ihr nicht durchblickt, was
gerade passiert, ich blick auch nicht durch. Ich AI einfach alles weg. Easy as fuck. Hallo.
So, jetzt müssen wir es gleich haben. Einfach, einfacher e-Spam. Drop noch was Gescheites,
nope. Oil. Ja, mit diesem Oil-Drop, das habe ich auch lange nicht gecheckt, was man damit
überhaupt machen kann. Damit kann man sich sein Amulet, wie heißt es? Ich hab vergessen,
wie das heißt. Man kann aufs Amulet nen Skill draufcraften. Hier zum Beispiel hab ich auf
dem Amulet Undertaker als Skill. Undertaker ist hier im Skilltree. Enoint, genau, wie auch
immer man das schreibt. Ehe, wie auch immer man das ausspricht, meine ich. Also sprich,
man kann sich den Skill ausm Skilltree auf sein Amulet craften, das ist richtig cool.
Und wenn man wissen will, was man dafür für Öle braucht, hält man einfach alt gedrückt
und geht über den Skill und lässt sich anzeigen, was man da braucht. Und der ist halt richtig
gut für Leichenexplosionsfeuerball-Stells, weil der mit 30% mehr Damage gibt. Es gibt
zwei mehr Leichen, die rumliegen. Also ich hab hier so ein Skill, der Leichen spawnt,
die ich dann explodieren lassen kann. Genau, und es gibt bisschen Life. Oh, das ist gut,
das brauch ich. Davon kann man nicht genug haben. Und da kann man sein Build, den hab
ich noch nicht einmal gesehen, den Typ in dieser Leak. Da kann man sein Build nochmal
richtig gut upgraden mit so einem Skill. Obwohl, gemerkt, der Skill kostet dann auch im normalen
Skillbaum keine Punkte mehr, weil der Skill kommt ja direkt aufs Amulet drauf. Das Porgeres
ist das. Huge Poggers. Okay, der Dude kann nix. Der kann nix. Können die Schuhe was?
Oh, ne. Mach doch bitte die Conqueror. Mach ich, nachdem ich Level Up hab. Ich hab kein
Bock da jetzt nochmal zu verrecken. Und ich bin schon zweimal sinnlos verreckt. Ich will
erstmal Level Up machen. Also ich mach jetzt noch im Zweifelsfall noch ein paar Maps, bis
ich Level Up hab. Und dann mach ich den nächsten. Weil, den brauch ich. Also ich hab, wenn ich
das nächste Level Up hab, dann skill ich hier einmal Stärke und mach glaub ich den hier
weg. 6% Life, das macht jetzt auch nicht fett. Und skill den hier rein. Spielst du grad online
oder offline? Online, man kann das Spiel nicht offline spielen. Also wie gesagt, das kann
man nicht offline spielen. Da können wir doch bei... Lohnt sich aber erst so richtig bei
hohen, also bei gelben Maps ist das nicht so, nicht so geil. Hab aber grad, ich kauf mir
noch ne gescheite Map. Hab ich noch, hab ich noch irgendwo ne rote Map hier? Nö. Alles
gemacht. Auch schon gemacht, ach kommt mal da, abgecrated. Werfen wir mal ne Alch Orb
drauf und gucken ob was gutes rauskommt. Elemental Increase, bla bla bla, okay. Kein Elemental
Reflect. Das Spiel sieht jetzt zu wild aus. Ja, ist, das Game hat auch seine Tücken, ja.
Vor allem, wenn man so ein Build macht mit so viel Explosionsstells. Headhunter irgendwie,
ja. Alles klar. Wow. Die hätt ich vielleicht sogar Quali machen sollen, ha? Endschonpa.
Wie heißen die Dinge eigentlich auf Deutsch, diese Maisel? Maisel für die Maps, wie heißen
die Dinge auf Deutsch, hab keine Ahnung. Diese Shizzles, Grizzles, Chizzles, wie auch immer
man es genau nennt. Morn KS, was, what is happening? Morn KS, es ruckelt.
90 FPS, ja. Wisst ihr? Instant Frame Drops merke ich sofort. Sucked. Ja.
Sonst legt ihr nix gescheites, ha? Äh, Müll. Wow.
So, knapp. Fast RIP. Ach, das war dieses Ding.
I hab ein Spiegel von Kalandra gefunden. Naja, kannst du es zellen. Kannst du es zellen.
Brauchen wir nicht. Oh, da ist Zebaro auch da. Ah, ja, ja.
Alter, ein A-Click-Aim heute.
Ah, wie sie explodieren. Wie sie einfach platzen.
Porgas. Guck einfach mal, bam. Einfach mal weiter weg.
Zebaro, ich lese gleich, was du geschrieben hast. Irgendwas mit Python 3 habe ich aus
dem Augenwinkel gesehen.
Jetzt dauert nicht mal lang noch mal Level ab. Ach, keine Ahnung, 2, 3 Maps, ha?
So, und wo ist jetzt mein Headhunter-Drop? Pippi-Hands.
Äh, Moment, habe ich den Boss schon gemacht? Ich bin gerade richtig braindead, habe ich
den Boss jetzt schon gemacht oder nicht? Nee, oh, kann der was?
Ich bin nicht so sicher, ob der was kann. Ich kite mal im Kreis, dann können die Börse
nämlich alle nichts. Kreis-Kreiten, beste. Kreisel-Kreisel-Kreiten.
Headhunter wird nicht angezeigt von Loot-Filter. Fuck. Stimmt, ich habe es vorhin rauskonfiguriert.
Und Mirrors habe ich auch rauskonfiguriert, weil ich meine, das ist einfach zu viel Clutter
dann, on screen, das muss man raus machen. Ok, gegen Kiten kann der nichts machen. Das
sacken die ganzen Bosse. Wenn man einfach nur sinnlos im Kreis kitet, sind sie useless.
Wow, wow, wow, wow. Wow, ist ja mal gut jetzt. Ich hoffe, es ist alles down. Alles down?
Nee, noch nicht ganz. Fast, fast down. Jetzt ist er down, oder? Ok, das ist wahrscheinlich
das da unten von komisches Schluckerding. Ob da irgendetwas gescheites bei ist? Braucht
man sowas hier nicht, oder? Breed Flask brauchen wir schon mal erinnert. Es sackt. Es hätte
Potenzial gehabt, aber nope. Keine Ahnung, was das ist. Das ist auch ziemlich schamist.
Auch knapp. Stell den Filter mal hoch. Ich hab den auf strikt stehen. Ich hab mir vorhin
ganz schön überlegt, ob ich den auf very strikt hoch stelle, weil der spammt ganz schön
viel rum. Wo hab ich jetzt die Maps hingeschmissen? Ich hab doch irgendwo noch ein paar gelbe Maps
gehabt. Maps. Die Musik ist vorbei, muss einer mal sagen. Relaxing Video Game Music,
was? Water Edition? Achso. Das ist schön entspannt. Aber das ist mir gerade ein bisschen zu entspannt.
Alone Pippenhands. Genau das Richtige für uns. Alleiner Kreiselgrind. Keiner Kreiselgrindet
hier. Eser. Lohnt sich das eigentlich, den Wahlopter drauf zu machen, oder ist das nur
bei roten Maps sinnvoll, das auszugeben? Maximum Player Resistance, na gut. Kann sich
lohnen. Ich trau da Sache nicht. Ich hab kein Bock wieder auf Elemental Reflect. Mods bleiben
gleich. Okay. Oh, also kein Elemental Reflect, okay. Guck mal, wir haben das Sana-Mission,
die machen wir gleich noch. Dann könnten wir fast Level-Up haben. Dann können wir auch
die Bosse machen. Das ist ne schöne Map, die ist schön Easy-Mode im Kreislaufen. Acht
mal, ich brauch ein paar Scrolls. Ja, so mag ich das. Einfach im Kreislaufen und alles
one-shotten. Excellent, oh. Was war da? Was ist das? Tog das was? Dream Fragments. Tog
das was? Ne, Crap. Geh mal trotzdem auf. So, wir kriegen eine rote Map. Links. Okay,
unidentified. Ne, das trau ich mich jetzt nicht dran. Wir machen die hier. Find Map Item,
Find Map Item, Divination Card Slave. Machen den. Auch bei den anderen trau ich mich grad
nicht ran. Machen lieber die 11er, da haben wir bessere Chancen, dass hohere Maps droppen.
Was, wenn du Alt gedrückt? Achso. Okay, das ist gut zu wissen. Also das heißt, du meinst
hier geht es auch bei normalen Maps? Weil, ja hatte ich ja schon. Oder nur bei Sana.
Achso, echt. Ich drücke doch gerade Alt. Aber wo sehe ich denn jetzt, als ich die schon
hatte? Kann auch sein, dass du das anschalten musst. Echt? Okay. Wahrscheinlich UI, hm?
Advanced Mod Descriptions vielleicht? Ah, ja das ist ja nice. Hätte ich das mal eher
gewusst. Da hätte ich nicht die ganze Zeit dumm auf dem Atlas rumgucken müssen. Das
ist Poggers. Das ist nicht nur Poggers. Das ist Poggers. Das ist französische Poggers.
So Poggers ist das schon. Wow, da will ich nicht reinlaufen. Mission, okay easy. Aber
ich mach das trotzdem alles noch. Weil das gibt fett EXP. Und EXP können wir gebrauchen.
Excellent EXP. Kann sein, dass das total ein Minimap ist? Die Map ist gut. Schön im Kreis.
Und alles wegbashing. So magisch Maps. So ist das schön. So könnten die alle sein.
Ich hasse die verwinkelten Maps, wo man fünfmal backtracking muss, weil man noch 20 Abzweigungen
hat. Ah, hier kann man wenigstens ordentlich mit Speed durchflitzen. Sack. Exed. So, das
soll hier noch 50 Monster sein. She baited. Was ist denn hier für ein Endgegner drin?
Ah, das fette Nashorn. Das macht Damage, wenn es einen hittet. Ja, aber das hittet mich
nicht. Weil es suckt. Guck mal, wie schlecht es ist. Ah, verkaufen wir. Ach, deswegen waren
noch 14 Monster drin. Verstehe. So, muss man mit Zana danach eigentlich reden, das ist
nicht gut. Ah, come on. Level up, please. Kann ja nicht mehr so lange dauern. Ah, okay.
Da ist irgendwas gespawnt aus dem, aus dem Gegner raus. Ja, so Maps sind toll. Die Gegner
sucken, die können nix. Gibt FedExp. Ah, so vorbei. Geht so. Oh, FedExp, das ist gar
nicht mal. Bam. Ja, gut, ich glaube, das mit der Kamera, das kriegen wir irgendwie nicht
mal gebacken, weil ich weiß echt nicht, was ich mir da kaufen soll. Hat einer von euch
eine ordentliche Outdoor-Kamera, die über WLAN geht, wo man auch per RTSP an Stream dran
kommt. Ansonsten bestelle ich mir echt mal die eine von AliExpress für 30 Euro und gucke,
ob die taugt, bevor ich mir irgendwie ein 250 China-Ding von Amazon bestelle. Oh, der
sackt. Guck mal hier, da kann er gar nix. Der ist ja richtig pepega. Der Kacknoob, der
Kacknoob. Null. Dash. Wird gselt. Wobei, das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht, um da mal
gegen den Enchant zu probieren. Gar nicht so übel, als Base, oder? Plus 66 Schleif, 11
Chaos, standardmäßig schon. Keine Ahnung, ob man damit was machen kann. Da habe ich mich
noch nicht so in der Tiefe mit beschäftigt mit der ganzen Crafting. Sowohl Harvest-Craft
als auch normales Craften, bin ich nicht so der Pro. Was haben wir denn da jetzt für
eine? Ups. Machen wir die? Gar nichts. Hauptsache Level Up, das müsste doch dann fast schon
sein. Yup, Udils müssen wir jetzt nicht schauen. Watch Dogs 2, Who Cares, Alter, Watch Dogs
2. Wen juckt denn das, bitte schön. Watch Dogs 2, ich glaube es geht los. Lass das im
Jahr 2020 noch überhaupt jemand interessiert. Das Spiel für Hipster Hacker, für möchte
ich gern Hipster Hacker. Ich glaube Watch Dogs wird für immer so in den Köpfen der
Leute drin bleiben wie, Alter, ein A-Clicking. Das Spiel, was die geile Grafikdemo hatte
und dann übelst downgraded rausgekommen ist. Verständlicherweise, weil die PS4 und die
Xbox One hatten halt nicht so viel Power, wie sie sich das vielleicht erhofft haben. Da
waren ja die Konsolenhersteller schon ein bisschen mit dran schuld. Hätte wäre das
rein auf dem PC gelaufen, kein Ding, ne? Dann sah das mit Sicherheit auch so aus und
hätte man auch machen können. What? Aber auf dem PC verkaufen sie halt nichts. Und
wofür ich Watch Dogs immer in Erinnerung behalten werde, dass es das Spiel mit den
verwirrendsten und meisten Versionen ever war. Watch Dogs hatte irgendwie 8 verschiedene
oder 10 verschiedene, 20 verschiedene Versionen und keine davon hatte alles. Das war echt total
für'n Arsch. Ja, Watch Dogs Versions. Muss mal kurz gucken, dass ich nicht verrecke.
Ich wusste es ja, da kommt, da will mich irgendwas chibaten von der Seite. Muss ich euch klar
mal zeigen, das ist echt lächerlich. Oh, wo ist hier was gedroppt? Manchmal fliegen
die Feuerbälle so weit, dass da Offscreen-Dinger droppen. Du weißt gar nicht, wo du hinlaufen
musst. First World Problems, ne? Wenn man so schnell killt, dass die Gegner Offscreen
sterben und man nicht weiß, wo man hinrennen muss. Bist du eigentlich hyped auf Cyberpunk?
Äh, ich hab das Gefühl, ich bin der Einzige auf der Welt, der nicht hyped auf Cyberpunk
ist. Und das, obwohl ich Riesen-Witcher-Fan bin. Außer auf der Switch. Der Switcher suckt.
Der Switcher ist gut, der Switcher nicht. Aber ich bin, ich kann mit dem, mit dem Steampunk-Dings,
oder nee, ich sag nicht Steampunk, mit dem, äh, da Future Cyberpunk Neon City-Gedöns-Setting
irgendwie nix anfangen. So ne Fantasy-Witcher-Welt ist mir lieber. Sollte es hier nicht nen Endgegner
geben? Auf der Map? Irgendwas? Oder hab ich den schon gebashed? Oder ist der da oben?
Ich glaub, der ist da oben und ich bin noch nicht lang, kann das sein? Ah, nee, oh nee.
Okay, die Ecke, die war sehr wichtig auf der Map. Die musste da noch unbedingt hin.
Ohne die Ecke wäre es nicht möglich gewesen, diese Map zu randomisen. Okay, jetzt aber,
hat die Map kein Boss? Oder stand der Boss irgendwo rum und ich hab ihn gebashed und hab
es gar nicht mitgekriegt? Doch, ich hab den Boss gebashed und hab sie mitgekriegt. Vermute
ich jetzt einfach mal. Genau, also Watchdog Versions, pass mal auf. Das ist nicht normal.
Ja, sind die bei Ubisoft komplett von Allergut und Geister verlassen? Warum macht man für
ein Spiel 10 Versionen? Was ist denn bei denen nicht richtig? Und es gibt nicht eine Version,
die alles hat. Also wenn man alles haben möchte, muss man sich das, das und das oder so kaufen.
Das ist Ubisoft, Alter. Dafür werd ich Watchdogs immer in Erinnerung behalten. Das ist das
Spiel mal mit den meisten und verwirrendsten Versionen, was es bisher gegeben hat. Also
das hat noch kein anderes Game geschafft, in der Art und Weise so wird zu sein wie Watchdogs.
Okay, eine Map noch, dann haben wir Level Up. Easy as fuck. Kann ich specken. Outlook, Waste
Pool Outlook. Wir machen eine stinknormale Map ohne alles. Ich will jetzt nicht noch
verrecken. Sollte auf jeden Fall reichen. Ach so, die ist gut. Da kann man mehr oder
weniger geradeaus rennen. Und die Gegner sacken auch, das ist wunderbar. Mir geht das Mana
aus, das hatte ich noch nie. Da muss man schon ganz schön spammen, dass einem hier das Mana
ausmacht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Es hat mich einfach gefriest an der Box. Monka
Corona. Boah, das hat mich gerade geschockt. Die ganzen bunten Effekte sehen ganz aus.
Wenn du das, wenn du das die ganze Zeit siehst, macht es eigentlich eher, macht dich das
gefährlich im Kopf. Das ist aber von dem Bild, das ist, also das ist mit Microtransactions
an, ist es weniger bunt als standardmäßig und deswegen habe ich auch die Microtransactions
an. Weil ohne Microtransactions ruckelt das Spiel, also das hat Frame Drops, ist oft dumm.
Das mache ich gleich, wenn du mal kurz gucken, dass hier alle Gegner weg sind. Moment, ich
habe die Map clear und habe kein Level Up. Ok, dann ist gut, dass hier so ein Teil ist,
damit kriege ich jetzt Level Up. Auf, auf, let's go. Boah, Frames. Frames, please. Ok,
wir spammen jetzt einfach hier rein und die werden alle verrecken. Sag mal, kriegt man
von den Mops keine XP? Doch, doch. Ich kriege einfach nur eh wenig XP hier. Oh come on,
ich will einfach nur Level Up haben. Zu bunt, zu schnell, ich erkenne auch nichts. Aber
wem das zu viel ist, die meisten anderen Builds sind bei Weitem nicht so. Aber es ist, früher
oder später hat das Game schon ein bisschen Effekt Overlord, egal bei welchem Build, aber
nicht so krass wie hier. Ich glaube es nicht, ich habe kein Level Up gekriegt. Der Dude
sagt. Ich habe jetzt eine komplette Map durch Speed durchgerusht und krass. Was gibt's hier
noch für eine? Ja komm, die machen wir jetzt noch, easy. Hinten rauf, einfach mal durchgerannt
und gut ist. Ich meine, für das Vitzelchen XP noch, da will ich noch den einen Boss machen.
Ich brauche nämlich noch jede Menge Watchstones für die Map und für den Atlas.
Wie es platzt, aber guck mal, so ein Buddelviech. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das richtig heißt,
so ein Tunnelding, wo manchmal so eine Höhle rausspawnt. Ich glaube, Preach heißt es glaube
ich. Bam, Level Up, easy. Jetzt kann ich verrecken, jetzt ist mir egal. Hast du eigentlich noch
manchmal Kontakt zum Commander, klicklos? Ich wirklich, nee. Hatten wir früher auch
nicht oft. Hatten wir früher auch nicht oft. Jetzt mache ich aber nicht mal YouTube Zeug,
wobei ich insofern da ganz froh bin, weil das würde mir die letzte Motivation rauben,
dass, wenn ich ein Video auf YouTube hochlaue, dass das zumindest noch akzeptabel sich angeguckt
wird. Ist das In-Game-Musik? Nee. Keine In-Game-Musik. In-YouTube-Playlist, Free-Chillstep 2020,
sonst was. Zum Beispiel Herr Gartenstelz. Ja, das verstehe ich bis heute nicht. Das
war eher eine YouTube-Algorithmus-Sache. Die machen wir gleich. Also wie gesagt für
Leute, also das Spiel braucht definitiv Epilepsie-Warnung. Ok, wo ist hier was gedroppt? Ich sehe es
nicht. Da unten. Oh komm mal, ist das ein gutes? Keine Ahnung, ob das was Gutes ist. Nee,
das ist ein Sack. Huge Sack. Ok. Ok, ich bin da. Ok, ich bin da. Ok, ich bin da. Ok,
ich bin da. Was auch immer, ich habe irgendeine Prophecy erfüllt. Und, dass ich mitgekriegt
hätte, dass ich eine habe. Ok Kassia, auf gehts. It's branching exile. Oh, das war doof. Oh,
da unten sind ja auch noch jede Menge. Fuck. Ich muss das mit dem da oben wegbashing. Das
sind so Dinge, da tue ich mir immer echt schwer bei diesem Setup. Gut, ich meine jetzt kann
ich einfach spammen und die kriegen aufs Sack. Oh, oh, was ist mit den Mops los? Warum schießen
die da? Was soll das hier? Ich weiß, dass es den Gartenstalls immer noch auf YouTube
als Vorschlag gibt manchmal, weshalb auch immer. Aha, die Fossils sind teilweise richtig
viel wert. Exzellent, da ist ja richtig gutes Zeug dabei, guck mal mal. Müll, also Müll
für mich. Das könnte sogar ganz gut sein, wenn man das braucht. Na, wobei. Naja doch,
das glaube ich ganz gut für Leute, die Nahkampf, aber wer macht schon Nahkampf-Bilds? Increase,
könnte auch ziemlich gut sein für jemand, der Chaos Melee Damage oder so macht. Sackt,
Sackt auch. Ok, jetzt können wir noch einen Boss machen. War Zeit. Oh, ah, alles voll.
Ok, 23. So, ich brauche noch mal einen Tap mehr. Einen Tap brauche ich noch. Danach
freue ich mich auf, versprochen Game. So, welchen Boss machen wir denn jetzt? Erstmal
gucken, ob der da oben nicht noch was zu sagen hat. Was will eigentlich Helena von mir? Oder
wer hat denn da was über dem Kopf? Ist das Helena? Ich erkenne es nicht. Ähm, komm.
Macht mal ein bisschen Platz, Jungs und Mädels. Aina und Ivali, äh, Gachibas. Ah nee, die
hat den Tempel am Start. Ne, das machen wir jetzt nicht. So, machen wir noch mal die Boss-Map.
Du machst Nachkampfbilds, ok. Also diese League, ich war kurz davor, ein Nachkampfbild anzufangen.
Ich habe mich ja ein bisschen schlau gemacht, was für ordentliche League-Starter und sowas
von den ganzen Pros empfohlen werden. Und da war unter anderem irgendeinem, was war denn
das? Irgendeinem Melee-Bild. Ich kriege nicht mal zusammen, was für eins. Da war ich kurz
davor mal mit einem Melee-Bild zu starten, aber ich habe mir gedacht, nee, das geht immer
nach hinten los, mach mal OP-Caster-Bild und gut ist. Und das war auch die beste Variante.
Zack, zack, äh, aha. Alles nett. Ok, also Skill-Point und danach einen
Respecken dahin und dann wird gleich noch einer Respeckt für mehr Defense. Und wenn
ich dann morgen ein bisschen live upgrade, dann ist das richtig OP, dann ist rote Maps
easy mode. Vom Damage her ist er jetzt schon easy mode. Ist das die Map mit diesem komischen
Ziegen-Mander als Boss? Der geht mir immer auf den Kekser, dauert so lange. Alter, wie
explodiert, null. Ok, den Boss mal mal klein. Erstmal Rest, clearen. Die Dinger sind immer
ganz gut. Guck mal, ich habe schon wieder ein Bubble-XP voll. Das ist noch so eine Kranke,
die ich aus Dark habe, da ich das Bubble nenne. So ein XP-Slot. Dark waren das immer Bubbles.
Wo steckt der Fabian eigentlich, frage ich mich gerade. Weiß nicht, wie ich da jetzt
drauf komme. Ich frag mich gerade, was der Fabian treibt. Der Frazier. Der Fabian spielt
Diablo 3. Was, auf der Switch? Warum Diablo 3 auf der Switch? Der soll mit mir POE spielen,
easy. Der soll mit mir POE spielen, viel geiler. Soll er POE spielen, dann machen wir ein übelstes
Duo-Kombo. Einmal Aura-Bots und Einmal AE-Farmen. Du kannst ja dem Game übelste OP-Partys machen.
Artplank, der soll 10x durch. Mindestens 10x durch. Aber BDO spielt ja schon eine Weile
nicht mehr. Aber warum auf der Switch? Was ist da los? Was? Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das
was taugt, muss man mal nachgucken. Peinlich nicht. Gucken wir mal kurz, ob das was taugt.
Ja, ja, ist gut. Grand Spektrum. Genuch Resys hat doch eh fast jedes Bild. Ah nee, Crimson.
Naja. Nee, nix wert. Sucked. Lackt das bei euch auch? Immer? Permanent? Nee, eigentlich
lagts bei mir überhaupt nicht. Einzige was ich hab sind teilweise Mega-Frame-Drops, wenn
wir mal wieder 50 Gegner auf einmal explodieren. Kann man den One Cycle'n den Dude eigentlich?
Geht das? Nee, oder? Der springt immer weg nach einer Zeit. Wär geil, wenn man den One
Cycle'n könnte. Weil der Gegner, der Boss, der fuckt mich immer richtig ab. Der braucht
so lang für. Jaja, ist ja gut. Der wechselt immer die Location. Ja, das hab ich fast schon
vermutet. So, Boss. Easy, easy win, easy kill, easy life. Okay, der hält dies. Woah, woah,
monka, monka. Oh, macht er so'n Damage? What the fuck? Was ist da los? Gut, dass ich grad
Level-Up hatte. Keine Poison Immunit- äh, ja, das ist richtig. Egal. Ist vollkommen
egal. Ich hab eh keine, ich hab eh keine Axe zu verlieren. Mach ich jetzt einfach noch
mal. Beim dritten Mal spätestens ist er down. XP zu verlieren gibt's eh nicht. Ups. Mach
jetzt einfach, ich mach jetzt einfach ein Town-Portal auf davor. Und dann sterb ich
zweimal. Oder ist, äh, muss ich jetzt wirklich hier noch mal durch? Gut. Oh, KS, der macht
aber echt Damage, der Dude. Okay, ich spam jetzt einfach drauf, bis er down ist. Okay,
ja. Ja, so einfach kann's sein. Einfach Damage machen. Einfach mehr Damage machen als er.
So. Und dann setzen wir schon mal irgendwo einen. Lore, lul, und wieder weg. Ähm, ups. Ja, sehr
schön. Den hätten wir, mal gucken, ob das was taugt. Increased Effect of Offerings,
das könnte potenziell gut sein, allerdings sind die anderen Stats, äh, Crap. So, machen
wir noch den letzten Boss. Da haben wir auch schon ein bisschen Procrast gemacht heute.
Und morgen mach ich da ein bisschen Gear Upgrade. Morgen erst mal ganz normal wieder Homeoffice
und wenn ich fertig bin, mach ich ne Runde Gear Upgrade und dann abends normaler Stream
ohne PoE. Oder mal gucken, ob ich morgen Stream mache. Bin ja mittlerweile so aktiv,
was das angeht. Glaub, so aktiv war ich nicht mal auf YouTube. Normalerweise ist der Stream
Inhalt ja ein ganz anderer. Ich glaub, das liegt auch daran, dass ich hier andere Sachen
machen kann, wie auf YouTube. Auf YouTube muss ich immer noch ein bisschen Gaming bezogenen
oder aktuellen Geschehnissen bezogenen Big Brain Talk machen. Und hier kann ich Technik
Kram machen. Und das Gute ist, wir haben sogar noch viele Leute dabei, die wissen, um was
es geht. Ich bin immer wieder begeistert vom Chat. Zwischen, zwischendurch, ne. Und ich
glaub, das können nicht viele Streamer sagen, dass sie begeistert von ihrem Chat sind. Ja,
das machen kann ich auch nicht. Guck, wenn ich Passive-Exhalts spiele, guck auch viel
weniger zu. Ist doch logisch. Interessiert ja auch nicht so viele. Es hat schon ein bisschen
was mit dem Inhalt zu tun. Äh, es geht hier eigentlich gerade ab. Ja, aber Stream ist kein
Mehraufwand. Naja, naja, ein bisschen schon. Also, es ist schon nicht ganz so Brain-RFK
vom Rechner sitzen, wie wenn ich alleine hier Passive-Exhalts-Kreisel-Crime mache. Ein
bisschen Chat gucken und vor allem ein bisschen labern. Auch dann, wenn man manchmal so jetzt
vom Rechner nicht labern würde, ist da schon dabei. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das
Gute halt am Streamsorn, also gerade bei mir, dass ich tatsächlich mal den Kram machen
kann, der mich interessiert. Ich meine, wir machen irgendwelche Linux-Geschichten, wir
bauen irgendwelche Heimautomatisierungs-Sachen, wir bauen irgendwas mit dem Raspberry zusammen
oder was auch immer. Ich muss es euch ja nicht erzählen, ihr kennt es ja, ne. Also sprich
das, was mich auch so interessiert. Und wenn mich gerade Gaming, Big Brain Talk nicht interessiert,
kann ich kein YouTube-Video machen. Aber auf Stream habe ich ja von Anfang an quasi das
in der Richtung gemacht. Und was ich halt cool finde, dass wir halt echt so richtig viele
haben, die Plan haben. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das für ein Thema war. Oder auch irgendwie
einer erzählt hat, was er mit seinem ESP32 macht. Oder wenn die Leute da teilweise Dinge
auffallen, ich probiere das Tool zum ersten Mal auf. Irgendeiner im Chat, der sofort sagt,
ja, das geht so und so. Äh, habe ich, habe ich gerade irgendwie den Unique oder so übersehen?
Ah, noch ein so ein Ding. So, wo geht das hin? It's branching. Erst, erst mal freezen.
So, hier, stun. Und jetzt werden sie einfach weggesprayt. Easy as fuck. Äh, stun, freeze.
Erst mal hier unten alles wegsprengen. Dann wieder hochrennen, alles wegsprengen. Okay,
das wird jetzt anstrengend. Bisschen mehr freeze, ein bisschen mehr stun. Aber das ist
schön schon, wenn ihr das gefällt. Ich, ich, ich bin echt, ich bin echt froh. Muss, muss
ich ja, kann ich ja nicht oft genug sagen. Ähm, dass es die Leute halt auch interessiert.
Also, auf wie viele Ideen mich der Chat auch schon gebracht hat, wo ich so gar nicht dran
gedacht hätte. Und was natürlich auch immer cool ist. Äh, was, was genau stirbt denn
hier bitteschön grad nicht? Ah, jetzt. Äh, wo war ich jetzt, wo war ich jetzt grade? Ah,
keine Ahnung, hab ich vergessen. Uns hat's ja richtig gelohnt. Ähm, ja, was, was genau
war ich sagen wollen, was auch richtig cool ist, dass man oftmals einfach nur Stream anmachen
kann, ohne dass man eine Ahnung vorher hat. Ich mein, ich hab euch ja gefragt, wie ich
das machen soll. Und dadurch, dass die Leute dann irgendwas wissen wollen oder irgendwas
fragen oder irgendeinen Link schicken oder so, hat man immer zwei, drei Stunden was zu
tun. Das ist übelst poggers. Äh, Leute, ich bin ziemlich brain, brain afk, ich hab vergessen,
wo das Portal war. Wo war denn das Portal zum Boss? Irgendwo da hinten, ne? Irgendwo
hier rechts. Ja. Ach, die ist das. Das ist die mit den Wellen drumherum. Ähm, und,
Cho, ich muss sagen, oder C2HO ist es wahrscheinlich eher, nicht Cho. Ähm, bei den China Streams
ist es auch so, ich bestell viel mehr, als ich brauch. Total, total sinnlos. Oh, oh.
Es ist total sinnlos. Ich bestell, ich bestell so viel China Kram, den kann ich im Leben
nicht verwenden. Und gerade durch meine bescheuerte Angewohnheit, wo ich euch ja auch immer dazu
überreden will, das zu machen, äh, nie eins zu bestellen bei Elektronikrahmen, sondern
immer, oh, oh, jetzt hab ich nicht aufgepasst, jetzt hab ich, ah, Gott. Na gut, ich hab
eh keine XP verloren, weil ich keine XP hab. Die hat mich jetzt einfach geschreckt. Dazu
gibt's nur noch zu sagen. Ähm, genau, ich bestell ja immer, ich hab ja schon oft gesagt,
ich bestell nicht nur einen Teil, wenn ich in China was bestelle, sondern immer mindestens
drei, besser fünf. Deswegen, ich hab so viele Kisten mit unsinnigen Sachen hier. Das letzte
eigentlich unsinnige, haben wir uns vor ein paar Tagen im Stream angeschaut, dieser USB-Switch.
Ich hab da zwar ein Anwendungsgebiet für, aber ich hab 10 Stück bestellt und 10 Stück
brauch ich im Leben nicht. Walk of Shame, ja. Vor allem, der Boss war schon mehr oder
weniger down. Oder? Lul. Irgendwann brauchst du mal bestimmt, ja. Wahrscheinlich. Ich geb
hier wenigstens einen ordentlichen Life-Roll. So. Exell, jetzt haben wir die Bosse auch noch
gemacht, jetzt hab ich ein bisschen höheres Atlas-Level. Jetzt haben wir, äh, nicht
das hier, ich mein, das, was ich im Map-Device hab. Nee, sind immer noch vier Prozent. Aber
wann steigt das denn? Das steigt, glaub ich, das steigt, glaub ich, nur, wenn man Atlas
completed, ne? Das steigt nicht einfach so durch Watchstones. Halbes WoW, nee, gar nicht.
Also mit WoW hat's so wirklich nix zu tun. Da fehlt ja der komplette MMO-Aspekt. Das
ist eher Diablo. Und mehr Diablo 2 als Diablo 3. Okay, nice. Mal gucken, was ich respecten
kann. Also ich schiel hier aktuell so auf diesen Live-Note, weil der ist absolut unwichtig
für den Rest, den Rest kann ich nix wegnehmen. Gucken wir mal, 4700. Machen wir mal live
weg. Oh, das macht ordentlich was aus, wisst ihr das mal? Die 6% live machen 100, irgendwas
150 leben oder so aus. Nicht schlecht. Oh. Aber damit hab ich weniger Damage Spikes drinne.
Das mach ich jetzt erstmal. Und nächstes Level-Abspeck steh ich hier wieder rein. Und
danach weiß ich eh nicht mal, was ich specken soll. Ich mein, ich bin jetzt Level 90, nee
89. Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, was ich specken soll danach. Das hier wahrscheinlich. Reduced
your increased maximum life, reduced mana cost. Wahrscheinlich speck ich das hier. Zumindest
sagt es auch der Build-Guide. Das hier. Dann kann ich noch 1-2 Level machen bis 95. Danach
ist er e-Utopisch da, das zu erreichen, außer tagelang grind. Von den letzten zwei Skill-Points
hol ich mir wahrscheinlich noch den Crystal hier unten. Das war's. Wo ich auch ein bisschen
drauf schiele noch, sind die Feuer-Nodes hier oben. Da weiß ich nicht genau, ob ich
die noch irgendwie reinkriege. Aber sinnvoll ist, was anderes wegzumachen. Wie gehts der
Katz? Der Katz gehts gut. Der Katz ist so dick wie noch nie vorher. Ich auch. Ich mach jeden
Tag mittlerweile Sport, aber durch die ganze Homeoffice-Geschichte, ich hab's sogar wieder
zugenommen. Das ist der Wahnsinn. Ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll. Es bleibt mir
nix anderes übrig, wie mich besser zweimal am Tag ne Stunde was machen. Und vielleicht
wenn man den ganzen Tag daheim sitzt durch Homeoffice ein bisschen weniger futtern. Ich
muss nicht jeden Tag Mittagessen bestellen. Pepo-Fett. Weniger essen als verbrennen easy.
Ja, genau so siehts aus. Quick-Muffs. Easy. Nur noch Baguette essen. Wobei das ist auch
nicht Low Carb. Weniger Softdrinks. Ich trinke keine Softdrinks. Das ist eine Sache, die
ich zum Glück mir nie angewöhnt hab. Ne, ich trinke keine Softdrinks. Ich trinke eigentlich
fast nur Wasser und Tee. Auch ohne Zucker. Das schmeckt mir auch so. Oder ab und zu ein
bisschen Wasser mit ein bisschen Saft. Fertig. Lieblingstee. Was echt exotisch ist, aber
ziemlich gut schmeckt ist, aber den hab ich grad nicht da. Der schmeckt echt gut. Ist,
okay. Ja. Okay. Geht nicht. Also der schmeckt echt gut, aber den hab ich schon ne Weile
nicht mehr da, weil das ist echt wie wenn du ne Mahlzeit rein haust. Meinst du das liegt
an Adblock? Ähm, da hast du echt das Gefühl du hast was gegessen. Ja gut, Chat. Da haben
wir ein bisschen Kreisel-Crying heute. Ich konnte meine Kreisel-Crying-Sucht stillen.
Wir haben sogar ein bisschen Progress gemacht. Morgen mach ich dann Offstream den Gear-Upgrade.
Brauch auf jeden Fall mehr Life. Damage ist top. Gibt's nichts zu meckern. Weißt du wie
du dich zum Fahrradfahren überredest? Ne, keine Ahnung. Wirst du vom Physix Grill eingeladen?
Ne, dann guck ich mal morgen Abend. Vielleicht bin ich morgen Abend wieder da. Mal schauen.
Aber dann mit normalem Stream. Hast du dir mal Persona angesehen? Du meinst die, die,
die, diese RPG, Anime-RPG-Geschichte auf der Playstation? Nö. Nie großartig. Du maps
das O2- und Vodafone-Netz. Das ist gut. Das ist echt ne Big-Brain-Idee. Da kann man sogar
Voder von O2 noch ärgern, wie scheiße der Netzausbau ist. Oh, ich seh grad, es ist 22.12.
Leute, ich muss off. Morgen ganz normal wieder Homeoffice. Und höchstwahrscheinlich morgen
dann Nachmittag wieder streamen. Mal gucken. Bis dann, macht's gut, CU.